You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多压力。每天阅读、在昏暗的光线下看东西、长时间盯着屏幕，这些情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光，甚至夜间驾驶都会导致视疲劳。所以，没错，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，通过定期的眼科检查来呵护并监测眼睛健康非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，只需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部疾病和健康问题。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.cavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. Welcome back to our second drink of Fun Run Part 1. We have some really fun stories from Kate Flannery in this episode. She shares her story of how she came to be on the office and also her memories about the scene where Michael hits Meredith with his car.
要查找您附近的门店并预约 99 美元起的 OCT 扫描眼科检查，请访问 specsavers.ca。眼科检查由独立的验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。欢迎回到我们《Fun Run》第一部分的第二杯饮品节目。在这一集中，我们有一些来自凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）的非常有趣的幕后故事。她分享了自己是如何加入《办公室》剧组的，以及她对迈克尔开车撞到梅雷迪思（Meredith）那一幕的记忆。
It is one of the most famous stunts we did on the office. And lady, I was talking to Kate about this scene. And she told me that this Meredith car moment is so popular with office fans that when she goes to fan conventions, the convention organizers will get a red car and then you can get a photo op with Kate on the hood of the car and then you get to like drive the car like Michael. Oh my gosh. Is that crazy?
这是我们在《办公室》中拍摄的最著名的特技之一。女士，我当时正和凯特聊这一幕。她告诉我，梅雷迪思被车撞的瞬间在《办公室》粉丝中非常受欢迎，以至于当她去参加粉丝见面会时，主办方会准备一辆红色的车，这样你就可以和凯特在引擎盖上合影，然后你还可以像迈克尔那样开车。天哪，这太疯狂了，不是吗？
There's all these pictures of Kate on the hood of the car. All right. So I went back and rewatch this episode. Oh, lady, it's so good. And when we first broke down the episode, I talked a lot about how many great deleted talking heads there are. Well, I really wanted to share Stanlies with you. It would have come right at the beginning after Michael tells the bullpen
到处都是凯特在引擎盖上的照片。好了，我回去重看了这一集。哦，女士，太棒了。当我们第一次拆解这一集时，我谈到了有很多很棒的删减片段。嗯，我真的很想和你们分享斯坦利（Stanley）的片段。它本应该出现在迈克尔告诉大家他刚刚开车撞了梅雷迪思之后。
that he just hit Meredith with this car. And Leslie David Baker nails it. Let's hear it. You ran over Meredith this morning in the parking lot. And saved her life. Yes. by taking it to the hospital. They cut back the Christmas gift.
莱斯利·大卫·贝克（Leslie David Baker）演得太到位了。我们来听听看。你今天早上在停车场撞倒了梅雷迪思。而且救了她的命。是的。通过把她送到医院。他们削减了圣诞礼物。
Then no personal calls from work. Now we get run over. He's like, what's next? And there are also a lot of candy bag alts for all of these talking heads. Everyone's, of course, you know, reacting to the news about Meredith. I love these two from Creed. Are you ready?
然后工作时间不准打私人电话。现在我们又被车撞了。他就像是，接下来还会发生什么？这些谈话头（talking heads）片段中也有很多即兴发挥。每个人当然都在对梅雷迪思的消息做出反应。我喜欢克里德（Creed）的这两个片段。准备好了吗？
Yes. Creed says, Meredith? Meredith died 20 years ago. The next one. Who the fuck is Meredith Palmer? Well, there's also a deleted Michael talking head that cracked me up because it's one of those where he's trying very hard not to take responsibility for the accident. You have to hear it.
是的。克里德说，梅雷迪思？梅雷迪思 20 年前就死了。下一个。梅雷迪思·帕尔默（Meredith Palmer）到底是谁？嗯，还有一个被删减的迈克尔的谈话头片段让我笑得前仰后合，因为那是他极力想推卸事故责任的片段之一。你一定要听听。
Maybe she hit me. You ever think of that? She hit me? I don't know whose fault it was. I wasn't exactly looking at the road. The road. It could have been anyone's fault. She could have thrown herself on his car.
也许是她撞了我。你有没有想过这一点？她撞了我？我不知道是谁的错。我当时并没有盯着路看。路。这可能是任何人的错。她可能是自己扑到车上的。
Yeah. all we know. Well, Jenna, you also did a great deep dive on rabies for this episode. And I wanted to add another nugget to your share. It comes from Adrian E. She says, quote, rabies can be acquired even if not bitten and you come in contact with saliva. Whoa. She gives an example. Two fishermen were trying to keep a rabid beaver out of their boat and both died from rabies from not so apparent cuts in the skin that we all have. Oh, so if the saliva gets into an open wound or a cut or something, you can acquire rabies that way. Isn't that crazy? Yeah.
是的。我们所知道的一切。嗯，珍娜（Jenna），你这一集还对狂犬病做了深入的研究。我想在你的分享中再加一点料。它来自阿德里安·E（Adrian E）。她说，引用：“即使没有被咬，只要接触到唾液，也可能感染狂犬病。”哇。她举了一个例子。两名渔民试图把一只患狂犬病的海狸赶出他们的船，结果两人都死于狂犬病，原因就是我们每个人身上都有的那些不明显的皮肤伤口。哦，所以如果唾液进入了开放性伤口或割伤处，你就会感染狂犬病。这不是很疯狂吗？是的。
Also, what the fuck with the rabid beaver? I mean, that sounds so scary. Truly. I feel like that might have been about what she said. Gosh, what's happening today? Sorry. Sorry, second drinks, listeners. Oh, my goodness.
还有，那只患狂犬病的海狸是怎么回事？我的意思是，听起来太可怕了。真的。我觉得她说的可能就是那个。天哪，今天是怎么了？抱歉。抱歉，第二杯饮品的听众们。哦，天哪。
I'm very proud of my ravey's deep dive in this episode, Angie, I've gotten a lot of letters from people saying thank you that they've woken up with a bat in their room and they've known to go to the hospital. Yeah, I was shocked about how many people wrote in sharing similar stories or what they learned from your share and how that's helped them prevent things. Yeah. I mean, lady, look at you. Look at me.
我为这一集里关于狂犬病的深度解析感到非常自豪，安吉（Angie），我收到了很多人的来信，说谢谢我，因为他们醒来发现房间里有蝙蝠，他们就知道该去医院了。是的，我很震惊有多少人写信分享类似的故事，或者他们从你的分享中学到了什么，以及这如何帮助他们预防了危险。是的，我的意思是，女士，看看你。看看我。
Well, speaking of fan mail flurries, we also got one from people noting that I did not do fast facts for this episode or for the job. part one. And I guess in the episodes, I don't even address it. That's because we had the Paul Lieberstein interview at the top of show for Job 1. And we had the Kate Flannery interview for the top of show for Fun Run Part 1. You know, I saw those comments to Lady and what cracked me up is because I think we normally explain or tell people what's up. Yeah. So you read the summary and then we just go right into the interview. And so we were like, wait, wait, did I miss something? And it just cracked me up. And I also love Lady, how. much people clearly connect with your fast facts and notice when they're not any, so maybe it's
说到粉丝来信，我们还收到了一封信，有人指出我这一集或者《Job 1》第一部分没有做“快速事实”（Fast Facts）。我想在剧集中我甚至都没有提到它。那是因为我们在《Job 1》的开头有保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）的采访，在《Fun Run》第一部分的开头有凯特·弗兰纳里的采访。你知道，我看到了那些评论，女士，让我笑的是，因为我觉得我们通常会解释或告诉大家发生了什么。是的。所以你读了摘要，然后我们就直接进入采访了。所以我们当时就像，等等，等等，我错过了什么吗？这让我笑得不行。而且我也很喜欢，女士，人们显然是多么关注你的“快速事实”，并注意到什么时候没有它们，所以也许是时候把它们带回来了。
time to bring them back. To Office Lady 6.0. And that would be a no. All right. Lastly, I have one final moment to share from deleted scenes. It's at the hospital. Michael asks everyone to go around and say something nice about Meredith. And what Kevin says cracked me up, but I think you can also see John Cresensky trying not to break. It's just classic Kevin. Let's hear it. Why don't we go around the room and save one memory of Meredith? I'll start. I liked her jumpers. They reminded me of kindergarten.
回到《办公室女士》6.0。那是不可能的。好了。最后，我还有一个来自删减片段的时刻要分享。是在医院。迈克尔让大家轮流说一件关于梅雷迪思的好事。凯文（Kevin）说的话让我笑得不行，但我觉得你也能看到约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）在努力憋笑。这简直是经典的凯文。我们来听听。我们为什么不轮流在房间里说一个关于梅雷迪思的记忆呢？我先来。我喜欢她的背带裤。它们让我想起了幼儿园。
Jim? I'll always remember Meredith's back. That's all I can see from my desk. All that red hair over a nice, strong back. Sometimes I pretend it's Karatop, and he's going to turn around and tell a joke. Lady, it made me laugh out loud. when I heard it. And I remember filming those scenes.
吉姆（Jim）？我永远会记得梅雷迪思的背。从我的办公桌看过去只能看到这些。那一头红发下有一个漂亮、结实的背。有时我假装那是卡拉托普（Caratop），他会转过身来讲个笑话。女士，我听到的时候笑出了声。我记得拍摄那些场景的时候。
Yeah. There's so much more that didn't make it in the original episode, but we were laughing so hard. We got so tickled. I remember I did that laugh where I was crying. Mm-hmm. And poor Kate had to lay there with her eyes closed while we were breaking and having to start over.
是的。还有很多内容没有进入原始剧集，但我们当时笑得太厉害了。我们被逗乐了。我记得我笑得眼泪都出来了。嗯哼。可怜的凯特不得不闭着眼睛躺在那里，而我们却在崩溃，不得不重新开始。
And oh my gosh, it was the type of laughing where it actually is painful because you're laughing so hard and trying not to laugh. Mm-hmm. I remember it. Oh, well, that was fun. And I think that's all we got. So here is our second drink of Fun Run Part 1 with Kate Flannery. I'm Jenna Fisher.
天哪，那种笑法真的很痛苦，因为你笑得太厉害了，又在努力不笑。嗯哼。我记得。哦，好吧，那很有趣。我想这就是我们所有的内容了。所以，这是我们与凯特·弗兰纳里一起录制的《Fun Run》第一部分的第二杯饮品。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. It's season four.
我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。这是第四季。
Season four. Holy glaucomole. It's Fun Run. It's Fun Run Part 1. That's right. Because Fun Run was an hour long episode. So once again, we're going to break it down into two parts. Today is Fun Run part one. Written by Greg Daniels. Directed by Greg Daniels. So much happens in Fun Run. It needs to be two episodes. It really does. Oh, for sure. For sure. Here is a summary of just Part 1. Yeah, let's hear it. Yeah, let's hear it. Okay.
第四季。天哪。是《Fun Run》。是《Fun Run》第一部分。没错。因为《Fun Run》是一集一小时长的剧集。所以我们再次将其拆分为两部分。今天是《Fun Run》第一部分。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）编剧。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导。《Fun Run》中发生了太多事情。它需要分成两集。确实需要。哦，肯定的。肯定的。这是第一部分的摘要。是的，让我们听听。是的，让我们听听。好的。
Michael accidentally hits Meredith with his car and breaks her pelvis. There's so much there already. Already. He gets the whole gang to visit her in the hospital and later discovers she may also have rabies. Angela asked Dwight to give medicine to her cat sprinkles while she visits Meredith in the hospital. But when Dwight returns, he announces that sprinkles. is dead and he put sprinkles in the freezer. In the freezer. Also, your television was on. Yeah, my television was on and Sprinkles is in the freezer. Meanwhile, everyone wants to know if Jim and Pam are
迈克尔不小心开车撞到了梅雷迪思，摔断了她的骨盆。那里已经发生了很多事。已经发生了。他让整个团队去医院看望她，后来发现她可能还患有狂犬病。安吉拉让德怀特（Dwight）在她去医院看望梅雷迪思时给她的猫“洒水”（Sprinkles）喂药。但当德怀特回来时，他宣布“洒水”死了，他把“洒水”放进了冰箱。在冰箱里。还有，你的电视开着。是的，我的电视开着，“洒水”在冰箱里。与此同时，每个人都想知道吉姆和帕姆（Pam）是否在约会。他们坚持说没有。他们说他们只是朋友。但凯文并不相信。凯文对此真的很执着。是的。为什么凯文这么关心？我不知道。他着迷了。因为这一集开始得太戏剧化了，我们觉得我们需要和这一集的核心人物谈谈。绝对。我们需要和凯特·弗兰纳里谈谈被那辆车撞的事。是的。所以，伙计们，凯特和我们聊了聊。萨姆（Sam），你能播放采访吗？
dating. They insist they're not. They say they're just friends. But Kevin is not convinced. Kevin really has a bee in his bonnet about it. Yeah. Why does Kevin care so much? I don't know. He's obsessed. Because this episode begins so dramatically, we felt like we needed to speak with the woman at the center of this episode. Absolutely. We need to talk to Kate Flannery about getting hit by that car. Yes. So, guys, Kate chatted with us. Sam, will you play the interview?
凯特·弗兰纳里今天在这里，伙计们，带着她的小茶杯。嗨，凯特。你们好吗？见到你们真好。等等，我们得给你和那个茶杯拍张照。科迪（Cody），你能拍张照吗？它不小。这是一个普通大小的茶杯。那有什么小的？我不相信你。它看起来很小。它是普通的。天哪。你还有一个小杯子和碟子。事情是这样的。伙计们，凯特·弗兰纳里是最优雅的女士之一。她的家非常壮观。装饰得就像出自《建筑文摘》一样。是的，每一件小事都很棒。我一点也不惊讶你看起来如此精致，而且你正在用一个合适的杯子和碟子喝茶。天哪。哦，等等。
Kate Flannery is here today, you guys, with her tiny teacup. Hi, Kate. How are you guys doing? It's so nice to see you. Wait, we have to get a picture of you with that teacup. Cody, will you take a picture? It's not tiny. It's a regular-sized teacup. What's tiny about that? I don't believe you. It looks tiny. It's regular. Oh, my gosh. And you have a little cup and saucer. Here's the thing. Guys, Kate Flannery is one of the classiest gals. Her home is spectacular. It is decorated like it's out of architectural digest. It is, Every little thing is amazing. And I am not surprised at all that you look so put together and you're having your tea in a proper cup and saucer. Oh, my gosh. Oh, wait.
抱歉。重要的电话。抱歉，伙计们。抱歉。抱歉。刚接到一个重要的电话。抱歉。直播接听吧。
Sorry. Important phone call. Sorry, guys. Sorry. Sorry. Just getting important phone call. Sorry. Take it on air.
直播接听吧。是谁？让我们和他们谈谈。我想是潜在的垃圾邮件，所以我挂断了。抱歉。哦。我不能为了节目效果被锁在分时度假屋里。抱歉，伙计们。
Take it on air. Who is it? Let's talk to them. I think it was a potential spam, so I hung up on them. I'm sorry. Oh. I can't get locked in a timeshare just for you for the bit. I'm sorry, you guys.
我不能。见到你真好。你不明白。我们在一起工作了九年。年。我知道。哦，天哪。我知道。在这方面，它非常像一份真正的办公室工作。就像在办公桌前坐了几个小时一样。还有荧光灯？是的。我的意思是，那对你真的有影响。还有零食？得了吧。那是最好的零食。哦，天哪。我们有有史以来最好的食物。这是我爸爸每次来访时唯一谈论的事情。我总是问他问题，比如，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）今天和我们一起吃午饭了。那不是很棒吗？他就像是，你看到牛排了吗？就像，总是关于食物。
I can't. It's so good to see you. You don't understand. We spent every day together for nine years. years. I know. Oh, my God. I know. It was so much like a real office job in that respect. Just like hours at our desks. And the fluorescent light? Yes. I mean, that has a real effect on you. And the snacks? Come on. That was the best spread. Oh, God. We had the best, best food ever. It's all my dad ever talked about. All the years that he visited. And I would pepper him with questions about, so Steve Corell ate lunch with us today. Wasn't that great? And he was like, did you see the steak? Like, it was always about the food.
比尔·金赛（Bill Kinsey）。哦，凯特。见到你真好。还有珍娜，你们。你们。凯特，我们总是喜欢从询问人们是如何加入《办公室》开始。我实际上为试播集试镜了简（Jan）这个角色。艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）说，我觉得你真的很适合这个节目，但我不知道这是否是你的角色。
Bill Kinsey. Oh, Kate. It's so good to see you. And Jenna, you guys. You guys. Kate, we always like to start by asking people how they came to be on the office. I actually auditioned for the pilot for the part of Jan. Alison Jones said, I think you're really right for this show, but I don't know if this is your part.
所以很明显，他们对洛德·哈登（Lord Harden）采取了不同的方式。结果呢，你们拍了试播集。我记得那个夏天，我每周做一次限时的短剧节目。这是一个两分钟的短剧节目。所以字面上在两分钟时，灯就会熄灭。这是在好莱坞梅尔罗斯（Melrose）的一家剧院进行的现场表演，其中一个斯考拉（Scholar）兄弟，兰迪（Randy）在我之前做了一个短剧。他说，你一直在看那个英国节目《办公室》吗？
So clearly they went a different way with the Lord Harden. And lo and behold, you guys shot the pilot. I remember that summer, I was doing a sketch show once a week that was timed. It was a two-minute sketch show. So literally at two minutes, the lights would go out. It was this live show in Hollywood at this theater on Melrose with one of the Scholar brothers, Randy was doing a sketch right before me. He's like, have you been watching that British show The Office?
我太着迷了。他就像第一个真正告诉我这件事的人。我说，是的，我看过一点。他说，你得把整部剧看完。所以我有点着迷了。然后到了九月，八月底，九月初，我有一个试镜。我没能参加第一次，因为我和我阿姨在芝加哥。然后我来了，我想角色肯定已经被拿走了。几天后他们又进行了一次会议。
I'm so obsessed with it. He was like the first person to really tell me about it. I was like, yeah, I've seen it a little bit. He goes, you got to watch the whole thing. So I kind of got obsessed. And then come September, late August, early September, I, had an audition. I couldn't make the first one because I was in Chicago with my aunt. And then I just came, I figured the part was going to get taken. And they had another session a few days later.
我进去了，读了剧本。我记得艾莉森·琼斯说，不要化妆。通常在洛杉矶，你知道，这意味着睫毛膏，一些粉底。它意味着什么。它从来不真正意味着不化妆。他们就像字面上，她字面上拿着一盒纸巾。她说，不要化妆。擦掉它。走开，对吧？总之，然后我记得有几个我认识的芝加哥女演员也在那里，我觉得她们预订了一切。我想，我永远也得不到这个角色。
And I went in and I read. And I remember Allison Jones said, no makeup. And like usually in LA, you know, that means like, you know, mascara, some foundation. It means something. It never really means no makeup. And they were like literally, she was literally had a box of tissue. She's like, no makeup. Wipe it off. Get off, right? Anyway, and then I just remember there were a few actresses that I knew from Chicago that were there, and I felt like they booked everything. I'm like, I'm never going to get this.
但我只记得那个房间里有肯·夸帕斯（Ken Kwappas）、格雷格和艾莉森·琼斯。我敢肯定保罗·利伯斯坦也在，我敢肯定有迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）。我敢肯定所有的制片人都在那里，编剧制片人。这就像是我在试镜中经历过的最独特的体验。然后当我出来时，我回到家，然后艾莉森告诉我去高尔（Gower）再做一次，再做一次，做得少一点，少一点，少一点，做得少一点。然后当我从那里回到家时，我发现我得到了这个角色。什么？你在开车回家的路上就预订了它。这不是很奇怪吗？我没有手机，所以我不知道，直到我回到家。那是每个演员的
But I just remember that room was Ken Quappas and Greg and Allison Jones. And I'm sure Paul Lieber She was, I'm sure there were, you know, Mike Scher. I'm sure all the producers were there, the writer producers. It was like the most unique experience I think I'd ever had in an audition. And then when I came out, I got home, and then Allison told me to go to, gower and do it again, do it one more time and do less, less, less, do less. And then by the time I got home from there, I found out that I got the part. What? You booked it on the drive home. Isn't that weird? And I didn't have a cell phone, so I didn't know to I got home. That's every actor's
梦想。你没有手机，所以你不知道。那是那些日子，伙计。就像，你知道吗？他们联系不上你。你在家里发现的。我在开车回家的路上玩欲擒故纵。哇。好吧，凯特，我太兴奋了。因为当你那天走进片场时，凯特和我一直在做一个叫《Bitch Planet》的即兴表演。全女性即兴表演。我们已经做了好几年了。然后突然之间，我的好朋友要在我身后坐好几年。那真是太神奇了。谁知道呢？当周日晚上我们的观众只有四个人时。在10点钟。凯特，你还记得你的试镜场景是什么吗？是的，它是来自，你知道，
dream. You didn't have a cell phone so you didn't know. Those were the days, man. Like, you know what? They couldn't get a hold of you. You found out at home. I was playing hard to get on the drive home. Wow. Well, Kate, I was so excited. because when you walked on the set that day, Kate and I had been doing an improv show called Bitch Planet. All chick improv. And we'd been doing that for years. And then all of a sudden, my good friend was going to be sitting right behind me for years. That was just amazing. Who knew? When four people were in our audience on a Sunday night for our show. At 10 o'clock. Kate, do you remember what your audition scene was? Yeah, it was from, you know, the
联盟，这是对惊喜派对的整个反应，迈克尔读生日贺卡并疯狂地侮辱梅雷迪思。是的，太棒了。是的，太棒了。太尴尬了。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。
the alliance, it was the whole reaction to the surprise party and Michael reading the birthday card and insulting Meredith like crazy. Yes, amazing. Yeah, it was so awesome. So awesome. So awkward. So awful. So awful.
生日快乐。生日快乐。好吧，凯特，我们在节目中谈了很多关于一旦我们在那个牛棚里拍摄，我们都在场景中。所以我们都是彼此的背景。这非常独特。在很多节目中不是那样的，对吧？所以我们谈论了我们在背景中做的事情。我们谈论了菲利斯（Phyllis）是如何看盖茨（Gates）的。记得吗，她看了盖茨的房子好几年。我记得他们告诉我们，他们告诉我当我预订这份工作时
Happy bird day. Happy birthday. Well, Kate, we've talked a lot on this show about how once we were filming in that bullpen, we were all in the scene. And so we were all each other's back. background. And that's very unique. It's not like that on a lot of shows, right? So we've sort of talked about the things we did in the background. We talked about how Phyllis looked at Gates. Remember, she looked at Gates for her house for years. I remember they told us, they told me when I booked the job
我应该带文书工作，因为他们真的希望我们看起来像是在工作。我喜欢那个建议。我觉得它太，就像它是方法派，因为那样没有人会突然表现得像他们在工作。他们实际上在工作。而摄像机捕捉到了他们，这更有意义。所以我第一季实际上带了我的税单。我正想说，凯特，我记得你打开邮件，就像有……哦，是的，我做了。我做了。我带了一袋东西。我想我还偷偷读了一本书，这在办公室里有时也是人们会做的事情，你知道。特别是梅雷迪思。嗯，我不知道。梅雷迪思读很多书吗？也许不是。我显然迷上了纸牌游戏。那是我的主要背景
that I was supposed to bring paperwork because they really wanted us to be looking like we were working. And I loved that suggestion. I thought it was so, like it's so method because then no one is suddenly acting like they're working. They're actually working. And the camera catches them, which makes so much more sense. So I actually brought my taxes the first season. I was going to say, Kate, I have a memory of you opening your mail and like having... Oh, yeah, I did. I did. I brought a bag of stuff. And I think I also like snuck reading a book, which is kind of like a thing that people do it in an office anyway sometimes, you know. Especially Meredith. Well, I don't know. Does Meredith read a lot? Maybe not. I got into Solitaire, clearly. That was like my main background
选择。但那是因为我的后脑勺在其中很多部分，所以我无法，我的屏幕在我的电脑上一直被捕捉到，所以我宁愿在最后一分钟去某个文件，我宁愿投入纸牌游戏，因为我知道我可以马上回到它，我觉得梅雷迪思一直用一个游戏进行多任务处理是一件有趣的事情。好吧，你变得非常非常擅长它。实际上克里德和我会有很多很多比赛，我打败了他。我仍然有点纠结于他们告诉你来片场并带上文书工作的事实。珍娜，他们告诉你了吗？
choice for so much of it. But that was so much because the back of my head. head was in so much of it that I I can't my screen was caught all the time on my computer so I would just rather than like go to some file at the last minute I would just dump into solitaire because I knew I could just get right back into it and I thought it was a funny thing for Meredith to be multitasking all the time with a game so stupid well you became really really good at it I actually creed and I would have many many a competition and I whooped his ass I am still sort of hung up on the fact that They told you to come to set and bring paperwork. Jenna, does they tell you that?
你知道，我不记得那个具体细节了，但我确实带了一些。我过去经常写下我的购物清单。我一直在，或者只是我做的通用待办事项清单。我会写日记，你知道，但用纸和笔。太有趣了。现在，珍娜，你和我有一个我们创造的小系统。你还记得吗？你必须记得。
You know, I don't remember that specifically, but I did bring some. I used to write down my grocery list a lot. I was constantly, or just general to-do lists I would do. I would journal, you know, but with a paper and 10. So funny. Now, Jenna, you and I had a little system that we created. Do you remember this? You have to.
这是我对这个节目最美好的回忆之一。什么？什么？我们有特定的人们的真实文书工作的盒子。是的。菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）买了医疗记录。这太离奇了。还有这些收据。
It's one of my fondest memories of the show. What? What? We had specific boxes of other people's real, like, paperwork. Yes. Phil Shea bought, like, medical records. It was bizarre. And these receipts.
我有一整套系统，我在装订，我有一整套，某些东西会匹配。然后我会把它们带给你，然后你会批准或不批准签名。我只记得这个整体。哦，天哪。太棒了。这太神奇了，而且非常具体。关于它，我最喜欢的事情，凯特，是我们会在没有人会欣赏的深层背景中做这件事。这真的只是为了我们。我们永远不会脱离角色。我们会争论，不是互相争论，而是像与系统争论。是的，是的。是的，我们对他们如何添加这些感到生气，
And I had this whole system where I was stapling, and I had a whole, like, certain things that would match. And then I would bring them to you, and then you would approve or disapproved sign. I just remember this whole. Oh, my God. was fantastic. It was amazing and it was very specific. My favorite thing about it, Kate, was that we would do this in the deep, deep, deep background when no one would appreciate it. It was really just for us. And we would never break character. And we would argue not with each other, but sort of like with the system. Yes, yes. Yes, we were mad at how they had added these,
是的，这些字母数字字符与任何表格都不匹配。而且无法输入到计算机中。我们有一整套我们对公司感到生气的事情，我们会做。我们做了。哦，天哪。这是世界上最好的工作。这是我见过的最可爱的事情，我怎么会和你们一起在片场这么多年？我不知道。
yes, these alpha numeric characters that don't match any of the forms. and are impossible to input into the computer. We had this whole thing we were mad at at corporate that we would do. We did. Oh, my gosh. This was the greatest job in the world. This is the cutest thing that I, how was it that I was on set with you guys all these years? I didn't know.
我不知道你们在做这个。你知道奥斯卡·努涅斯（Oscar Nunez）会做什么吗？有了这些健康记录，奥斯卡会找到一个非常奇特的，他会圈出来并突出显示，让它变得非常重要。他会在场景中间以极大的权威把它递给我。它会写着类似“眼睑上有球状肿块，可能是麦粒肿，建议排脓”之类的东西。我会说，哦，天哪，我正在场景的背景中读这个。我们非常尊重，虽然显然我们从未在节目中泄露任何人的名字或医疗状况。
I didn't know you guys were doing this. Do you know what Oscar Nunez would do? With these health records, Oscar would find one that had something really peculiar and he'd circle it and highlight it and make it very important. and he would hand it to me in the middle of a scene with great authority. And it would say something like bulbous mass on eyelid, probably sty, recommended to drain of the pus. And I'd be like, oh my God, I'm reading this in the background of a scene. We were so respectful, though, obviously we never gave away anybody's name or medical condition on the show.
我想说我记得那些表格是经过编辑的，就像真实的个人信息被涂黑了一样。是我对表格做了那个吗？我想我们对表格做了那个。我字面上认为我们做了，因为我记得有时有一点，但不是全部。不是每一个，是的。我确实记得地址被涂黑了。但总之，伙计们，知道在那些日子里你可以买到旧的医疗记录有点令人毛骨悚然。我相信现在它们都是计算机化的了。
I want to say I have a memory that those forms were redacted, like that the real personal info was blacked out. Did I do that to the forms? I think we did it to the forms. I literally think we did because I remember sometimes there were a little bit, but not everything. Not every, yeah. I do remember addresses being blacked out. But anyway, guys, it was sort of creepy to know that you could buy old medical records in those days. I'm sure now they're all computerized.
而且日期也是来自像三十年前。就像，你知道，1960年代。是的，80年代是一个大的，是的，是的，太离奇了。我喜欢我们试图安抚人们，而事实是我们显然拥有了我们不应该拥有的东西。哦，天哪。但你知道吗？让我们继续试图证明为什么它是可以的。好吧，没关系。
And also the dates were from like three decades ago. It was like, you know, 1960s. Yeah, the 80s was a big, yeah, yeah, it's so bizarre. I love how we're trying to reassure people when the truth is we clearly had the things we shouldn't have had. Oh, my God. But you know what? Let's keep trying to justify why it was okay. Well, it's fine.
没关系。在邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）发生的事情留在了邓德·米夫林。我们没有分享任何。没错。敏感材料。但我会说我喜欢关于那个和文书工作的真实性，它保持了，它只是保持了一切。它就像镜头的焦点。
It's fine. What happened at Dunder Mifflin's State at Dunder Mifflin. We did not share any. That's right. Fentative material. But I will say what I loved about that and the realness of the paperwork, it kept, it just kept everything. It was like a little focus for the lens.
是的。我最喜欢的事情之一是他们有成堆成堆的某种来自这些办公室的时间码文档。它们在非常薄的纸上，就像圣经页一样薄，你知道吗？是的。然后它们里面有所有的小碳素片。有时我会闻碳素片。因为我喜欢那个味道。
Yeah. One of my favorite things was they had stacks and stacks of some type of time code documentation from these offices. And they were on really thin, like, almost like the pages of a Bible thin, you know? Yes. And then they had all the little carbon slides in them. and I would sometimes smell the carbon size. Because I like the smell.
它就像记号笔的味道。我喜欢那个味道。这是《E True Hollywood Story》现在。安吉拉正在吸毒。安吉拉有时在背景中嗅碳素。这就是你进入角色的方式。我不知道。好吧，你知道，这很有趣，因为肯·夸帕斯会做那件事，你知道，就像他来的时候的一般基调。
It's like the smell of like a Sharpie. I like the smell. This is the E True Hollywood story right now. Angela is getting high. Angela was sniffing the carbon in the background sometimes. This is how you got into character. I don't know. Well, you know, it's funny because Ken Quappas would do that thing, you know, like the general tone at the beginning when he would come.
这都是其中的一部分。就像实际上，你知道，拍摄我们工作，只是工作，就像，你知道，谁在工作？这很有趣。人们问我，你是怎么保持角色的，或者其他什么？我觉得那是我们的办公桌。所以剧组真的不允许坐在我们的办公桌前。所以，在这方面，它确实感觉像一份办公室工作。就像你字面上走进片场，直接走到你的办公桌前。它有点像专注和具体，真的非常棒。它让我们所有人都保持在游戏中。同样，你知道吗，我不会坐在任何人的办公桌前。
And this was all part of it. just like actually, you know, filming us working, just working and being like, you know, who are you working? It's funny. People have asked me like, how did you stay in character or whatever? I feel like those were our desks. So the crew really wasn't allowed to sit at our desks. So it was, it really did feel like an office job in that respect. Like you would literally walk in to set and just go right to your desk. It was kind of like focusing and specific and really wonderful. And it kept all of us in the game. And likewise, you know what, I wouldn't sit at anybody else's desk.
不。就像我永远不会只是去坐在菲利斯的椅子上。不。对吧？那是她的空间。有时雷恩（Rain）会坐在我的办公桌前和布莱恩（Brian）谈论梦幻足球。对吧。我不得不去把他踢出我的座位。
No. Like I would never just go sit down in Phyllis's chair. No. Right? That was like her space. Sometimes Rain would sit at my desk to talk fantasy football with Brian. Right. And I would have to come kick him out of my seat.
但我对这个过程有如此大的尊重。我只是觉得焦点总是放在我们节目的正确位置。是的。是的。而且我觉得我并不总是有很多台词，显然，但我感觉有什么东西我觉得我是在为我们所处的现实保持空间。这对我来说非常重要。我一直非常意识到这一点。好吧，我们超级兴奋地和你谈谈你在这一集中做的这个惊人的特技。我的意思是，天哪，凯特，你被车撞了。你被车撞了。你读到这一集时的第一个想法是什么？好的，我字面上说，她活着吗？我字面上说，梅雷迪思活着吗？我马上就说了。然后，就像，我后来读到，就像，有文章说其中一个编剧决定，你知道，他们想推销梅雷迪思没有活下来。然后他们认为那太黑暗了。格雷格认为迈克尔杀死了其中一名员工太黑暗了。哦，天哪。是的。你怎么从那里面回来？是的，我不确定。我不确定。但我当时就像，但我记得，就像，我非常意识到这一点，因为我想，我知道这不是肥皂剧。就像这可能是它。但我们第一次拍摄它时，字面上，他们几乎把它演得像梅雷迪思是一个他刚刚越过的减速带。因为就像你躺在地上，他从你身上滚了过去。我字面上在轮子下面。我们拍完了这一集，然后我想两周后，戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers），我们获得艾美奖的剪辑师，对一个插入镜头有一个想法，他认为这比我们拍摄的要有趣得多，也就是梅雷迪思撞到玻璃。
But I just had such respect for the process. I just feel like the focus was always in the right place for our show. Yeah. Yeah. And I feel like I didn't always have a lot of lines, obviously, but I felt like there was something that I felt like I was kind of holding the space for the reality that we were in. And that was very important to me. I was always very conscious of that. Well, we are super excited to talk to you about this amazing stunt that you did in this episode. I mean, holy cow, Kate, you get hit by a car. You get hit by a car. What was your first thought when you read this episode? Okay, I literally said, does she live? I literally said, does Meredith live? I said it right away. And then, like, I've been reading later that, like, there's been articles saying that one of the writers decided that, you know, they wanted to pitch that Meredith didn't live. And then they thought that was too dark. Greg thought it was too dark for Michael to have killed one of the employees. Oh, my God. Yeah. How do you come back from that? Yeah, I'm not sure. I'm not sure. But I was like, but I remember, like, I was so conscious of it because I was like, I know this isn't a soap opera. Like this can be it. But the first time we shot it, literally, they played it almost like Meredith was a speed bump that he just like went over. Because like you were laying on the ground and he rolled over you. I was underneath the wheel, literally. We finished shooting the episode and then I think two weeks later, Dave Rogers, our Emmy winning editor, had an idea for an insert shot that he thought was a so much more interesting than what we had shot, which was Meredith hitting the glass.
他问我们的UPM肯特·佐博纳克（Kent Zobornak）尝试一下并展示给我看。就像，肯特做了。你觉得你会做吗？我的意思是，他显然不认识我，因为我会说是的。我完全会说是的。我正想说，你会说是的。我会的，但第一季，我记得格雷格，有一个德怀特和迈克尔穿着像《迈阿密风云》里的克罗克特和塔布斯的镜头，来自万圣节派对。你记得吗？
And he asked our UPM Kent Zobornak to try it out and show it to me. Like, Kent did it. Do you think you'd do it? I mean, he obviously did not know me because I would have said yes. I totally would say yes. I was going to say, you would say yes. I would have, but season one, I remember Greg, there was a shot of Dwight and Michael dressed like Crockett and Tubbs from Miami Vice from the Halloween party. Do you remember that?
是的。是的。他们让我打扮成麦当娜。我记得那就像，那就像我在那里的第二个星期。我就像，哦，好吧，我会成为麦当娜，无论如何。就像他们真的去做了。我的意思是，我就像1987年的麦当娜。我穿着像胸衣。
Yes. Yes. And they had me dress up like Madonna. And I remember it was like, it was like maybe my second week there. And I was like, oh, okay, I'll be Madonna, whatever. And like they really went for it. I mean, I was like 1987 Madonna. I was wearing like a Bousier.
这太疯狂了。我只是在背景中。我觉得关于那个有一些东西。就像我有责任尽可能地全力以赴。我不知道。我就像有点准备好做任何事。因为我记得格雷格说，如果你这样做可以吗？我就像，当然。
It was nuts. I was just in the background. And I thought there was something about that. It was like my responsibility to do whatever as full out as possible. I don't know. I was like kind of up for anything. Because I remember Greg saying, is it okay if you do this? And I was like, sure.
就像，当然。所以那开始了。整个梅雷迪思传奇，在做完所有事情后成为完整的麦当娜。好吧。但我实际上觉得做身体喜剧太有趣了，因为我有这么好的时间。我的意思是，我整个职业生涯做那个一直都很开心。但就像这绝对是另一个水平。所以字面上当我们去拍摄它时，我们不得不再次拍摄它。
Like, of course. So that started. The whole merit of the saga, being full Madonna after it did all. Right. But I actually felt like it was so much fun to do the physical comedy because I have such a good time to. I mean, I've always had a good time doing that my whole career. But like this was so up another level for sure. So literally when we went to shoot it, we had to shoot it again.
史蒂夫没空。所以丹·比尔斯（Dan Beals），我们的PA，当时太年轻了，他穿着史蒂夫的夹克。衬衫。所以那是他们剪辑的手。而且，这是一个如此快速的滑动。就像，它，你知道。所以等等，丹在开车？好吧，他只是在车里。在车里。车是静止的。我从引擎盖中心开始。我不得不滚到玻璃上，然后从车上滚到一个巨大的垫子上。所以你有点不得不像用力滚进那个挡风玻璃上。你有点把你的身体猛撞进挡风玻璃，然后慢慢地从它上面滚到一个。停车场里的垫子上？是的。我记得在第四次或第五次拍摄后，格雷格带我
And Steve wasn't available. So Dan Beals, who was our PA, who was so young at the time, he had Steve's jacket on. shirt. So it was his hand that they would cut from. And it was, it's such a quick swipe. Like, it, you know. So wait, Dan was driving? Well, he was just in the car. In the car. Car was stationary. I started in the center of the hood. I had to roll up to the glass and then roll off the car onto a giant mat. And so you sort of had to like with force roll into that windshield on your own. You sort of slammed your body into the windshield and then slowly rolled off of it onto a. mat in the parking lot? Yes. And I remember after like the fourth take or fifth take, Greg took me
到一边，我们去了仓库入口后面的那个小巷，我们在那里拍摄，就像鸟，你知道，他们在那里举行鸟葬礼，你知道，那个小巷。是的，是的，是的。他说，好的，跟我来做一些开合跳。他就像和我一起做开合跳，只是为了让我真正放松。我非常爱格雷格。我的意思是，他太格雷格了，顺便说一句。他是最伟大的，就像最伟大的。这很有趣。我最近刚看到戴夫·罗杰斯发给我一个花絮，另一个，他们没用的另一个镜头。我实际上在里面做了一个额外的旋转，我实际上认为那有点更有趣。但我只是太习惯看那一件事情了。我觉得它只是让我感到惊讶。所以等等，在宇宙中有一个你滚的镜头，你向前翻了两次进入
aside and we went to the back where the warehouse entrance is in that alley where we shot, like where the bird, you know, where they had the bird funeral, you know, the alley. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's like, okay, come with me and do some jumping jacks. He was like doing jumping jacks with me just to get me really lose. I love Greg so much. I mean, he's so Greg, by the way. He's the great, like the greatest. It's funny. I just recently saw Dave Rogers sent me at an outtake, another, another take that they didn't use. And I actually did an extra spin in there, which I actually thought was a little funnier. But I'm just so used to watching the one thing. I think it just caught me by surprise. So wait, there is a take of you out in the universe where you roll, you flip forward twice into the
挡风玻璃？不，一次进入挡风玻璃，但然后我从车上翻了两次。哦。所以它就像，就像，这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。好吧，伙计们，在53秒，你可以看到凯特的脸贴在挡风玻璃上。我告诉你，在我们拍摄完那个之后，我记得他们把它用在剧集的宣传片中，因为它是第四季《Fun Run》的第一集。我记得，华金·菲尼克斯（Joaquin Phoenix）在最后一分钟取消了《今夜秀》。所以他们基本上因为宣传片问我。这太有趣了，就像他们实际上想上《今夜秀》。
windshield? No, once in the windshield, but then I flipped twice off the car. Oh. So it's like, like, it's insane. It's insane. Well, guys, at 53 seconds, you can see Kate's face up against the windshield. And I'm telling you, after we shot that, I remember they were using it in the promos for the episode because it was the first episode of Season 4 Fun Run. I remember, Joaquin Phoenix canceled at the last minute for the Tonight Show. So they asked me basically because of the promo. It was so much fun like they actually want to be on the Tonight Show.
所以那是我第一次那样做。那太棒了。好吧，凯特，凯特，你就像一个摇滚明星。我的意思是，我必须问你，虽然，如果你一次又一次地用力滚进挡风玻璃并滚下来，你酸痛吗？你喜欢……我们必须匹配我们之前拍摄的内容，因为他们不确定之前，如果他们要看到我们之前。所以我必须匹配衣服，我穿着短袖和像牛仔背带裤。
So that was the first time I did that. That was so awesome. Well, Kate, Kate, you're just like a rock star. I mean, I have to ask you, though, if you're rolling with force into a windshield over and over and rolling off, were you sore? Did you like... We had to match what we shop before because they weren't sure about the before if they were going to see us before. So I had to match the clothes and I was wearing short sleeves and like a denim jumper.
是的。就像幼儿园老师。我记得艾美奖就像下周，我到处都是淤青。我不得不使用像身体化妆。是的，因为我想如果他们知道他们要那样做特技，他们可能会给你垫上垫子并相应地给你穿衣服。完全。是的。是的。
Yeah. Like a kindergarten teacher. And I remember the Emmys were like the next week and I was so bruised. I had to use like body makeup. Yeah, because I think if they knew they were going to do the stunt that way, they probably would have padded you up and dressed you accordingly. Totally. Yeah. Yeah.
哦，天哪。这太疯狂了。好吧，凯特，你在节目中做了这么多特技。这是你最喜欢的吗？我想是的。这是我最喜欢的。我也喜欢成为，太奇怪了。当德怀特来的时候，我在男厕所隔间上面，我在平板支撑。
Oh my gosh. That's crazy. Well, Kate, you did so many stunts on the show. Was this your favorite? I think so. This was my favorite. I also loved being, so weird. I was on top of the men's room stall when Dwight comes, where I was planking.
梅雷迪思在平板支撑。是的。德怀特带着灭火器进来，只是把她吹进隔间。是的。我们使用了真正的男厕所，那里是Video Village，客人们，那两个浴室。是的，是的，是的，是的。他们放了一个奇怪的flim flam床垫在上面。我就像，手指交叉，我不要去另一边，因为另一边什么都没有。
Meredith is planking. Yes. Dwight comes in with a fire extinguisher and just blows her off into the stall. Yeah. We used the real men's room where Video Village were the guests were, those two bathrooms. Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah. And they put like this weird flim flam mattress on top. And I was like, fingers crossed, I don't go the other way because there was nothing on the other side.
因为我不得不平衡。这太疯狂了。但是的。而且它真的很痴呆。我就像，好的，这个，希望我不要落地太重，因为那样我会撞到马桶。这太离奇了。但它真的很有趣。我想给你的运动能力一些赞美。
Because I had to balance. It was so crazy. But yeah. And it was really dementia. I'm like, okay, and this, hopefully I don't land too hard because then I'm going to hit the toilet. It's so bizarre. But it's really fun. I want to give some props to your athleticism.
我知道安吉拉经常因为我的运动能力而责备我。我们来了。不，不，没关系。我不会再回到那个，除了我刚才做的。但是，凯，你非常运动。我的意思是，做所有这些特技，这并不让我感到惊讶。我的意思是，我们知道你在《与星共舞》上，你太棒了。但你也做了你的休息室表演，《灯罩》，好多年好多年。
I know that Angela has often chided me for my athleticism. Here we go. No, no, it's okay. I'm not going back to that any more than I just did. But, Kay, you are amazingly athletic. I mean, in doing all these stunts, it doesn't surprise me. I mean, we know that you were on Dancing with the Stars and you were amazing. But you also did your lounge show, The Lampshades, for years and years and years.
我记得来看你表演那个。你做这个深蹲。反复，你踢你的腿。我就像，哦，天哪，我觉得他们作为梅雷迪思和你在一起太幸运了，因为你有资格做这些特技。这太甜了。我觉得对我来说，这也是赋权。就像，我没有做头发着火的特技。我确实做了摩洛哥圣诞节停车场里的所有事情。我只是没有做头发着火。你做了蝙蝠。那太疯狂了。你真的卖力了。太疯狂了。然后我没有。实际上剃了我的头。我为此戴了一个秃头帽。所以我觉得那是两个，就像，我就像，好的。但我认为，我认为你让你的头发保持原样是可以的。你知道我在说什么吗？我知道。我想格雷格很失望，虽然。这就像我第一次就像，
And I remember coming to see you in that. And you do this deep squat. repeatedly, and you kick your leg up. And I was like, oh my gosh, I feel like they got so lucky with you as Meredith, because you were qualified for these stunts. That's so sweet. I feel like for me, too, it was empowering. Like, I did not do the stunt with my hair on fire. I did do all the stuff in the parking lot of Moroccan Christmas. I just didn't do the hair on fire. You did the bat. That was crazy. And you really sold it. So crazy. And then I didn't. actually shaved my head. I had a bald cap for that. So I feel like those are the two like, I'm like, okay. But I think, I think it's okay that you let your hair be. You know what I'm saying? I know. I think Greg was disappointed, though. It was like the first time I was like,
不，不那样做。就像，好吧，我们可以谈谈这一集中我们在医院里的那一刻吗？我们都来看你了。我，我对这个的记忆是，在不笑的情况下完成那些场景太难了。事实上，你看到我们崩溃了。完全。我在剧集中完全崩溃了。那是在《Fun Run》期间，是的。你对在医院拍摄有什么记忆？我记得有一个场景，德怀特谈论如果他们拔掉插头，你知道，基本上是能量。就像他们在浪费钱让你继续。
nope, not doing that. Like, well, can we talk a little bit about the moment in this episode where we're all in the hospital. We've all come to see you. I, my memory of this was, it was so hard to get through those scenes without laughing. In fact, you see us break. Totally. I fully break in the episode. That was during fun run, yeah. What are your memories of shooting in the hospital? I remember there was one scene where Dwight talks about the fact that if they pulled the plug, you know, basically the energy. Like they were wasting money keeping you going.
我喜欢当你就像，不要插头。不要拔掉任何插头。哦，天哪，太好了。我记得史蒂夫只是作为道歉的镜头，他试图从我这里得到道歉，而我不会道歉。我不会道歉。所以他只是决定爬进床里。我。我觉得我有一个轻微的延迟反应，但我就像，我只是开始尖叫，因为我就像，就像，好吧，我们也感到惊讶，因为他即兴发挥了。你甚至看到所有
I loved it when you were like, do not the plug. Don't pull any plugs. Oh, my God, it's so good. And I remember the take when Steve just as an apology, he's trying to get an apology out of me and I won't apologize. I won't apologize. And so he just decides to climb into the bed with. me. And I feel like I had a slight delayed reaction, but I'm like, I just started screaming because I'm like, like, well, we were also surprised because he improvised that. And you even see all
我特别喜欢你说“别拔插头，千万别拔任何插头”的那段，天哪，太精彩了。我还记得史蒂夫试图让我道歉的那场戏，他想让我道歉，但我就是不肯。我就是不道歉。于是他决定直接爬上我的床。我觉得我的反应稍微慢了半拍，但我当时就开始尖叫，因为我……好吧，我们当时都很惊讶，因为那是他即兴发挥的。你甚至能看到所有
of us, we sort of like freeze. And then we're like, Michael, stop up. Yes. Yes. It really took us by surprise. Totally. Totally. Well, Kate, another question we like to ask our guests is if they took anything with them when the show wrapped. How dare you? Oh, what do you? You have it. What are you having?
我们，我们有点像僵住了。然后我们说，迈克尔，停下。是的。是的。这真的让我们大吃一惊。完全是。完全是。好吧，凯特，我们喜欢问嘉宾的另一个问题是，当剧集结束时，他们是否带走了什么东西。你怎么敢？哦，你带了什么？你有什么？
Well, first of it, I have Meredith's purse. I always wore it like a, you know, like a cross. Yeah. Yeah. You satcheled it. And I left everything in it that was still in there. So this is why I still had the marriage union of Pamela Morgan Beasley and James Duncan Halpert.
嗯，首先，我有梅雷迪思的钱包。我总是把它像，你知道，像斜挎包一样背着。是的。是的。你把它当挎包背了。我把里面剩下的所有东西都留在了里面。所以这就是为什么我还有帕梅拉·摩根·比斯利和詹姆斯·邓肯·哈尔珀特的结婚请柬。
Is that our wedding? Yes, it's the program. So this is why. It's our wedding program. The wedding party. Yes. This is what I showed on some good news with John Cresensky when we did our wedding dance. Oh my gosh. Is that crazy? That is so, that you had just tucked it in your purse and you still have it. We would do that though. We would get prop purses. And like if we had props, we would just put them in our purse. Totally. Yeah. I have. I have, oh my gosh, what else do I have in here? I think I have. Do you have some old sides? I would always put my sides. Yes, I do all sides. I have Sweenie Todd from when Andy was performing. in that theater. Wow. And I have Church of Angels Cecilia Marie Halpert when she got christened. C.C.'s christening. Oh my gosh, Kate. These are amazing. I know. Well, Kate, fans love Meredith. And you know we're going to be hitting you up. We've got a few more episodes to cover before we're done here. Before we say goodbye, is there anything we can share with everyone, like where to find you, what you're up to?
那是我们的婚礼吗？是的，是节目单。所以这就是原因。这是我们的婚礼节目单。婚礼派对。是的。这就是我在和约翰·克拉辛斯基做“好消息”节目时展示的东西，当时我们表演了婚礼舞蹈。天哪。那太疯狂了吗？太疯狂了，你竟然把它塞在钱包里，而且还留着。不过我们确实会那样做。我们会拿道具钱包。如果有什么道具，我们就会直接放进钱包里。完全是。是的。我有。我有，天哪，我这里还有什么？我想我有。你有旧的台词页吗？我总是会放我的台词页。是的，我所有的台词页都有。我有安迪在剧院表演时的《理发师陶德》。哇。还有塞西莉亚·玛丽·哈尔珀特受洗时的天使教堂。CC的洗礼。天哪，凯特。这些太棒了。我知道。好吧，凯特，粉丝们很喜欢梅雷迪思。你知道我们会找你的。在我们结束之前，还有几集要讲。在我们说再见之前，有什么我们可以和大家分享的吗，比如在哪里找到你，你在忙什么？
Yes. I, well, on Instagram at the real Kate Flannery, on Twitter at Kate Flannery. I go to a little ramen place once a week in K-Tenheim. Don't say that. But I'm actually doing some charity work for Phil Abundance, which is the biggest food bank in Philadelphia. That's my hometown. I'm working with WMMR, which is the big radio station. They always have the big morning show with Preston and Steve. And I've been doing their show for years. And it's a little. literally like five minutes from my dad's house. Like I will roll out of bed. And if I'm in town, I just, and I occasionally sometimes let a four-letter word slip. So they literally have a button on their panel that says, the flannery button because there's a four-second, you know, five-second
是的。我，嗯，在Instagram上是“the real Kate Flannery”，在Twitter上是“Kate Flannery”。我每周去K-Tenheim的一家小拉面店一次。别说那个。但我实际上正在为“Phil Abundance”做一些慈善工作，这是费城最大的食品银行。那是我的家乡。我正在和WMMR合作，那是大广播电台。他们总是有普雷斯顿和史蒂夫主持的大型早间节目。我已经做他们的节目好几年了。而且离我爸爸家只有五分钟路程。就像我从床上滚下来一样。如果我在城里，我就去，而且我偶尔会不小心说漏嘴一个四字母的脏话。所以他们实际上在控制面板上有一个按钮，写着“弗兰纳里按钮”，因为有四秒，你知道，五秒
rule, like, oh, they had, whatever. Those FCC, gosh, it's crazy. But anyway, I love these guys so much. And they're making such a difference. Fill abundance is, they're doing a huge push. They always do it right before Thanksgiving. But in the meantime, you know, you guys can go to fillabundance.org. I'm going to be doing some little bit of press for them. And I'll be, you know. Kate, that is so great. And we should have mentioned that you are from Pennsylvania. Yes.
规则，比如，哦，他们有，随便吧。那些FCC，天哪，太疯狂了。但无论如何，我非常爱这些人。他们正在做出巨大的改变。Fill Abundance正在进行大规模的推动。他们总是在感恩节前夕这样做。但与此同时，你知道，你们可以去fillabundance.org。我会为他们做一点宣传。我会，你知道的。凯特，那太棒了。我们应该提到你是来自宾夕法尼亚州的。是的。
And that your family, your dad had a bar in Philly. What was the name of the bar? Lanoese Tavern. He was up all night trying to figure out a name. No, I'm just kidding. My grandfather came up with a name too. Well, Kate, we love that you are given back to Philly like that. And we'll definitely, you know, we'll put in our socials where people can find
而且你的家人，你爸爸在费城有一家酒吧。那家酒吧叫什么名字？Lanoese Tavern。他整晚都在想名字。不，我开玩笑的。我祖父也想出了一个名字。好吧，凯特，我们很高兴你这样回馈费城。我们肯定会，你知道，我们会把人们可以在哪里找到你的信息放在我们的社交媒体上
That would be awesome. Thank you so much. You guys. I love you. So great to see you. I love you, too. Thank you so much. This was amazing. You have to come back. I would love to. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions.
那太棒了。非常感谢。你们。我爱你们。见到你们真好。我也爱你。非常感谢。这太棒了。你一定要再来。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，仅仅因为是新的一年，并不意味着你必须成为一个全新的自己。但也许你想成为一个负担更轻的自己，一个更清醒的自己。是的。不是一个完全全新的自己，但也许你只是想专注于某一点。你想精进。是的。我喜欢那个。精进。嗯，治疗可以帮助更容易地识别是什么让你感到沉重，是什么可能在阻碍你。你可以更好地理解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。
I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. Mm-hmm. BetterHelp therapists can help.
我正在努力放下对小事的纠结。嗯。因为那些真的会累积起来。嗯。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。嗯。BetterHelp的治疗师可以提供帮助。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest, online therapy platform having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies. We are back. Angela, that was so great talking with Kate. She looks beautiful, stunning.
拥有超过30,000名治疗师，BetterHelp是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过500万人提供服务。BetterHelp让你很容易在网上匹配到合格的治疗师。注册并在betterhelp.com/office ladies获得10%的折扣。那是better, h-e-l-p.com/office ladies。我们回来了。安吉拉，和凯特聊天真是太棒了。她看起来很漂亮，令人惊艳。
We have been talking to a lot of people through Zoom. for our podcast. And most people show up like a hot mess. Not Kate Flannery. No. She looked amazing. And Kate, that was so fun and we can't thank you enough. And we have a lot to cover. We better get into it. Yes. Let's break down this episode, lady. First of all, Jenna, I would like to share with you what you were doing this week that we filmed this. Are you ready? Okay. Someone went digging into old emails. Oh, I'm kind of scared. Don't be scared. Although I could burn it to the ground, but so could you. Oh, dear. Okay. On July 31st, 2007, the whole cast got an email from Kent Zabornack. That said, hey all, for this Friday, August 3rd, here's our schedule for the day.
我们通过Zoom和很多人聊过天。为我们的播客。大多数人出现时都像一团糟。凯特·弗兰纳里不是。不。她看起来棒极了。凯特，那太有趣了，我们怎么感谢你都不为过。我们有很多内容要讲。我们最好开始吧。是的。让我们来解析这一集，女士。首先，珍娜，我想和你分享一下我们拍摄这一周时你在做什么。你准备好了吗？好的。有人去翻旧邮件了。哦，我有点害怕。别害怕。虽然我可以把它烧成灰烬，但你也可以。哦，天哪。好的。2007年7月31日，整个剧组收到了肯特·扎博纳克的一封邮件。上面写着，嘿大家，本周五，8月3日，这是我们当天的日程安排。
8.45 a.m. Check in with the NBC Universal Studios harassment seminar. This will be located on stage three. 9 a.m. harassment seminar, mandatory attendance. 10 a.m. costume fittings, wardrobe trailer. 11 a.m. Table read episode, fun run in the writer's trailer. Noon cast physicals. Is that the end of the email? Please call if you have any questions, Kent. Oh, that's it? That's it. I thought it was, first. of all, I thought this was an interesting perspective that you saw what a day would be like as we prep an episode. It is. Your buildup to like, would you like to know what you were doing? I guess I just wasn't expecting the answer to be, you attended a harassment seminar and got a physical. I mean, I just thought, like, what was I doing? I can't wait to find out. I mean, I have to say, I wouldn't pick this day to redo if a genie in a bottle ever gave me a wish. Okay, okay. Well, I just thought this was a very interesting perspective. A, it shows what we had to do to start a new season. And also, B, we filmed Fun Run part one and part two in August. Okay, this part of the episode, we're inside. But folks, we're going to be running outside. It's August. I just think, I just think this interesting perspective, Jenna. I love it. It's great. I just thought you were going to,
上午8:45。参加NBC环球影城骚扰研讨会。地点在三号摄影棚。上午9点。骚扰研讨会，强制参加。上午10点。服装试穿，服装拖车。上午11点。剧本围读，在编剧拖车里进行“Fun Run”那一集。中午剧组体检。邮件就这些吗？如果有任何问题请致电，肯特。哦，就这些？就这些。我以为，首先。我以为这是一个有趣的视角，让你看到我们准备一集时的一天是什么样的。确实是。你铺垫了半天，比如，你想知道你在做什么吗？我想我只是没想到答案会是，你参加了一个骚扰研讨会并进行了体检。我的意思是，我只是想，我当时在做什么？我迫不及待想知道。我的意思是，我必须说，如果神灯精灵给我一个愿望，我不会选择重过这一天。好的，好的。好吧，我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的视角。A，它展示了我们为了开始新的一季必须做的事情。而且，B，我们在八月份拍摄了“Fun Run”的第一部分和第二部分。好的，这一集的部分，我们在室内。但是伙计们，我们要去外面跑步。现在是八月。我只是觉得，我只是觉得这个视角很有趣，珍娜。我喜欢它。太棒了。我只是以为你会，
let me in on something more exciting. That's all. Then my cast physical. I don't know. And my wardrobe fitting. Well, I was very excited. Clearly, I was very excited to find this email from Kent. Well, I'm glad you saved it because that's a keeper. Oh, shut up. You're going to want to. You should scrapbook that. You shut it. What would Dwight say? Zip your lid. I probably deleted that email because I like to keep a tidy inbox. I love that you saved it, I think. I don't know what to say. How about we get into this episode?
让我知道一些更令人兴奋的事情。仅此而已。除了我的剧组体检。我不知道。还有我的服装试穿。好吧，我非常兴奋。显然，我非常兴奋能找到肯特发的这封邮件。好吧，我很高兴你保存了它，因为那是个宝贝。哦，闭嘴。你会想要的。你应该把它做成剪贴簿。你闭嘴。德怀特会说什么？闭上你的嘴。我可能删除了那封邮件，因为我喜欢保持收件箱整洁。我喜欢你保存了它，我想。我不知道该说什么。我们开始讲这一集怎么样？
All right, we start off with Michael eating some cereal. Yeah. And at nine seconds, my background, folks, you can see that red pot basket thing that fell out of Jan's box as she was leaving corporate. No, you're kidding me. It's sitting right there. Oh, my gosh. I love that. much. Yeah, she's put her things around the condo. Well, we had a big fan catch at this moment.
好的，我们从迈克尔吃麦片开始。是的。在九秒的时候，我的背景里，伙计们，你们可以看到那个红色的篮子，那是简离开公司时从盒子里掉出来的。不，你在开玩笑吧。它就放在那里。天哪。我太喜欢那个了。很多。是的，她把她的东西放在公寓周围。好吧，我们在这一刻有一个大发现。
From Hannah A, Robert F., Christine J., Adrian Gibbs, Chelsea Warren, and many others who wrote in to say that Michael is eating cereal from Wegmans. And Wegmans is a local East Coast grocery store. They wanted to know whose idea was it to feature these Wegmans. products. That would be Phil Shee. Yeah, I was going to say, have to be Phil Shea. He was so great about doing that kind of research.
来自汉娜·A、罗伯特·F、克里斯汀·J、阿德里安·吉布斯、切尔西·沃伦和许多其他人写信说，迈克尔吃的是Wegmans的麦片。Wegmans是一家东海岸的本地杂货店。他们想知道是谁的主意要展示这些Wegmans产品。那是菲尔·谢。是的，我正要说，一定是菲尔·谢。他在做那种研究方面非常棒。
But how in the world did Phil Shea get Wegman's raisin brand and Wegman's soy milk? I have no idea. I'm impressed. Listen, Phil Shea is the guy that knows a guy. He's got a guy. Phil Shea's got a guy. He's got a guy on the ground in Scranton going to the Wegmans in Scranton, which by the way, I looked it up is open seven days a week from 6 a.m. to midnight and is located at 1-315 Cold Spring
但菲尔·谢到底是怎么弄到Wegmans的葡萄干麦片和Wegmans豆奶的？我不知道。我印象深刻。听着，菲尔·谢是个认识人的人。他有人脉。菲尔·谢有人脉。他在斯克兰顿有一个人，去斯克兰顿的Wegmans，顺便说一句，我查过了，每周七天营业，从早上6点到午夜，位于1-315 Cold Spring
Road. There you go, folks. If you want to eat the raisin brand that Michael is eating, that's where you can get it. Add it to your Dunder Mifflin, Scranton tour. Exactly. Well, then Michael enters the bedroom to reveal that Jan is still sleeping. She's probably going to sleep for another few hours, he says. You can really see what she's doing to the condo in this. I mean, she has set up a vanity. There's a giant mirror. There's a clothes rack. I see two tall, enormous, like, candle things. There's a pink chair, but guess what? There's not. Well, Michael's little bed that he sleeps on during dinner party at the end of the bed? The bench at the foot of the bed that he says he sleeps on is not there yet.
路。就是这样，伙计们。如果你想吃迈克尔正在吃的葡萄干麦片，那就是你可以买到的地方。把它加到你的邓德·米夫林，斯克兰顿之旅中。完全正确。好吧，然后迈克尔走进卧室，发现简还在睡觉。她说她可能还要再睡几个小时。你真的可以看到她在这一集中对公寓做了什么。我的意思是，她设置了一个梳妆台。有一个巨大的镜子。有一个衣架。我看到两个高大的、巨大的，像蜡烛一样的东西。有一把粉红色的椅子，但猜猜怎么着？没有。好吧，迈克尔在晚宴结束时睡的那张小床，在床尾？他说他睡的床尾凳还没在那里。
I noticed that as well. Well, maybe I'll email you about it someday. Maybe Kent sent us an email about it. You can delete it because you like a tidy box. Oh my gosh. You're so mad at me about this email thing. But I like, when you listen back, when you listen back, Angela, I want you to hear like the anticipation that you built. I'm going to do it for you. I have an email that I found that is going to tell you what you were doing this week.
我也注意到了。好吧，也许有一天我会给你发邮件。也许肯特给我们发了一封关于它的邮件。你可以删除它，因为你喜欢整洁的收件箱。天哪。你因为这封邮件的事对我太生气了。但我喜欢，当你回听的时候，当你回听的时候，安吉拉，我想让你听到你建立的那种期待。我要为你做这件事。我找到了一封邮件，它会告诉你这一周你在做什么。
I have it. I'm going to tell you. And then you were like, I could burn you to the ground with some of my emails. And I'm like, what is she going to say? I said, you were like, 9, 8.45 a.m. check in for sexual harassment seminar. And I was like, wait, what? Hold up. That's where this is going?
我有。我要告诉你。然后你说，我可以把你的邮件烧成灰烬。我说，她会说什么？我说，你说，9点，8点45分，参加性骚扰研讨会。然后我说，等等，什么？等等。这就是要讲的内容？
Hold up. You said, oh, should I be scared? And I said, no. I mean, I have the ones that can burn it down. So do you. But not this one. Clearly not this one. Clearly not this one.
等等。你说，哦，我应该害怕吗？我说，不。我的意思是，我有那些可以烧毁一切的邮件。你也有。但不是这一封。显然不是这一封。显然不是这一封。
This week, you complied with your job and its requirements. Well, your new nickname is Tidy Box. So enjoy that. You know Box is another word for vagina. I know. Hence the double entendre. Is that how you say that? Oh, good Lord.
这一周，你遵守了你的工作及其要求。好吧，你的新绰号是“整洁盒子”。所以享受吧。你知道“盒子”是阴道的另一个词。我知道。因此是双关语。你是这么说的吗？哦，天哪。
Tidy Box. Okay. We, what's happened to us? Well, we've been friends a long time. That's what's happened. All right. I love it. Well, Michael's in his car now. He's excited, you guys. He has a talking head. He thinks it's going to be a good year. Jan is home. Jim is back. Ryan is at corporate. Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales team. He feels blessed. He does. He also is not paying attention. And then, bam! When he hits Meredith with his car. And we talked about this with Kate. What an amazing and exciting way to start the season, I have to say.
整洁盒子。好的。我们，我们怎么了？好吧，我们做了很久的朋友了。这就是发生了什么。好的。我喜欢。好吧，迈克尔现在在车里。他很兴奋，伙计们。他有一个采访镜头。他认为这将是美好的一年。简在家。吉姆回来了。瑞恩在公司。安迪和德怀特正在销售团队大展拳脚。他感到很幸运。他确实是。他也没有注意。然后，砰！当他开车撞到梅雷迪思时。我们和凯特谈过这个。我必须说，这是一个多么令人惊奇和令人兴奋的开始这一季的方式。
I was surprised. Even when I rewatched it, I was like, oh, God. Well, remember in her interview when Kate said that her first thought was, oh, my gosh, just Meredith live? And she heard that maybe there were some writers who had pitched that they kill Meredith. Do you know who they were? I got to the bottom of it. Oh, now, this is probably a better email. I was emailing with Greg Daniels and Justin Spitzer.
我很惊讶。即使当我重看的时候，我也想，哦，天哪。好吧，还记得在她的采访中，凯特说她的第一个想法是，哦，天哪，梅雷迪思还活着吗？她听说可能有一些编剧提议杀了梅雷迪思。你知道他们是谁吗？我查清楚了。哦，现在，这可能是一封更好的邮件。我当时在和格雷格·丹尼尔斯和贾斯汀·斯皮策发邮件。
And they told me that, yes, they spent one evening pitching on this idea that maybe Meredith died. But it's more than that. It's not just that Meredith died. What? Greg told me that first of all, the idea was that they would shoot this as a spy shot. So they would not have a camera inside the car. with Michael, it would just be a spy shot of him arriving at work for the day with the talking head as a voiceover.
他们告诉我，是的，他们花了一个晚上讨论这个想法，也许梅雷迪思死了。但不仅仅是这样。不仅仅是梅雷迪思死了。什么？格雷格告诉我，首先，这个想法是他们会把它拍成偷拍镜头。所以他们不会在车里放摄像机。和迈克尔一起，这只是他一天到达工作时的偷拍镜头，配上采访镜头的画外音。
Okay. He said that the pitch was that Michael would accidentally hit Meredith with his car and then thinking that no one could see him, he didn't want to leave any witnesses. And so in one pitch he backed over her to make sure she was dead. Oh, good Lord. Justin told me that there was a pitch that Michael would. go into his trunk and get one of those anti-theft devices called the club and then club her to death and then hide her body. Were they on drugs? Were they on drugs? I mean, seriously,
好的。他说，提议是迈克尔不小心开车撞到了梅雷迪思，然后认为没有人能看到他，他不想留下任何目击者。所以在一个提议中，他倒车压过她以确保她死了。哦，天哪。贾斯汀告诉我，有一个提议是迈克尔会走进他的后备箱，拿出那种叫“俱乐部”的防盗装置，然后把她打死，然后藏尸。他们嗑药了吗？他们嗑药了吗？我的意思是，说真的，
that is the end of the show. There's no coming back. What were they thinking? That's what Greg said. Greg said, of course, we could never do this, but it was a pitch that was discussed for some time. And he said there were a few writers who were fighting for it. They were fighting for Michael to accidentally and then purposely do Meredith-in. I need names. He wouldn't give me the names. I need names because I need to do a mental check on them. Holy cow.
那是节目的结局。没有回头路了。他们在想什么？格雷格就是这么说的。格雷格说，当然，我们永远不能这样做，但这确实是一个讨论了一段时间的提议。他说有几个编剧在争取这个。他们争取让迈克尔不小心，然后故意做掉梅雷迪思。我需要名字。他不会给我名字。我需要名字，因为我需要对他们进行心理检查。天哪。
So, yeah, that's what I found out. There was a moment where they were pitching that maybe maybe. Meredith doesn't make it. How? Craziness. Also, I definitely don't want to know any of their late-night pitches on Angela. Okay, thanks. Okay.
所以，是的，这就是我发现的。有那么一刻，他们提议也许，也许。梅雷迪思没挺过来。怎么会？疯狂。另外，我绝对不想知道他们关于安吉拉的任何深夜提议。好的，谢谢。好的。
All right. Well, let's get into this episode. There's a lot to discuss. We start out with Jim and Pam talking to the IT guy because Pam crash the computers. Looking for some celebrity sex tape? Yeah. we got a lot of mail about this. I did a little bit of a mini deep dive.
好的。好吧，让我们进入这一集。有很多要讨论的。我们从吉姆和帕姆和IT人员交谈开始，因为帕姆让电脑崩溃了。在找什么名人的性爱录像带吗？是的。我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。我做了一个小小的深度挖掘。
Well, let's see. Lydia Lind, Megan Harrison, Mary Newberry, and Chris Roa all wrote in to say, it seems out of character for Pam to purchase a celebrity sex tape.
好吧，让我们看看。莉迪亚·林德、梅根·哈里森、玛丽·纽伯里和克里斯·罗阿都写信说，帕姆购买名人性爱录像带似乎不符合她的性格。
Did your script say whose celebrity sex tape Pam clicked on or did you ever come up with your own idea of who it might be? Okay, Jenna, I think I know what the right writers were hinting at here because I googled, by the way, be careful Googling this, I googled Celebrity Sex Tape 2007. Yes.
你的剧本里写了帕姆点击了谁的名人性爱录像带吗？或者你有没有想过它可能是谁？好的，珍娜，我想我知道编剧在这里暗示什么，因为我谷歌了一下，顺便说一句，谷歌这个要小心，我谷歌了“2007年名人性爱录像带”。是的。
And the first thing that comes up is Kim Kardashian and her boyfriend were vacationing and made a video. And that got leaked and it was released March of 2007. And there was a ton of like chatter, you know, just everyone was talking about it. Right. And I think when the writers thought of this story idea, that's what they were thinking of. I don't have proof of that. But this was written in around June of 2007 and that had happened in March. Yeah. So it was in the zeitgeist. But I don't think Pam would click on that. Like is she? I don't think Pam would click on it. Is she kidding here? Maybe she's just trying to be coy or flirty or something. It definitely shocked me when she said it. And also she's at work. She's at front reception.
第一个出现的是金·卡戴珊和她的男朋友在度假时制作了一段视频。那段视频泄露了，并在2007年3月发布。有很多像闲聊一样，你知道，每个人都在谈论它。对。我想当编剧想到这个故事点子时，他们想的就是那个。我没有证据。但这是在2007年6月左右写的，而那件事发生在3月。是的。所以它在时代精神中。但我不认为帕姆会点击那个。她是吗？我不认为帕姆会点击它。她是在开玩笑吗？也许她只是想装作害羞或调情什么的。当她说出来的时候，确实让我震惊了。而且她还在工作。她在前台。
She's going to watch this and shut down the whole computer grid. I don't know. It was a little bit of a stretch for me when I watched it, too. I agree. Okay. Well, now Jim has a talking head. He talks about how he broke up with Karen. And it was really awkward because she came back and she said she wasn't going anywhere.
她要看这个，然后关闭整个电脑网络。我不知道。当我看的时候，我也觉得有点牵强。我同意。好的。好吧，现在吉姆有一个采访镜头。他谈到他是如何和凯伦分手的。这真的很尴尬，因为她回来了，她说她哪儿也不去。
And you can see Karen is letting him have it. They're in the kitchen. And as they're going at it, Phyllis and Angela shoot Pam. very judgy look. Yeah. Two minutes, 10 seconds. Judgy, Phyllis, and Angela. Oh, my gosh. Phyllis Angela combo sass. Combo sass! That's a lot of sass. And, um, but he said, you know, Karen said she wasn't going anywhere, but then the next day her desk was cleared off and he's single and looking. Yeah. He wrapped that up quickly. You know, this was a highly anticipated episode because we had this big cliffhanger from the last season of Jim asking Pam on a date.
你可以看到凯伦让他发泄。他们在厨房里。当他们争吵时，菲利斯和安吉拉给了帕姆一个非常评判的眼神。是的。两分十秒。评判的菲利斯和安吉拉。天哪。菲利斯和安吉拉组合的刻薄。组合刻薄！那真是太刻薄了。而且，嗯，他说，你知道，凯伦说她哪儿也不去，但第二天她的办公桌就清空了，他单身，正在寻找。是的。他很快就结束了那段关系。你知道，这一集备受期待，因为上一季吉姆约帕姆出去约会有一个巨大的悬念。
And here now Jim's saying he's single. Pam has a talking head where she says, oh yeah, we went to dinner a few times. We talked through his breakup, but we're just good friends. And it's really nice to be friends again. Well, I'm with Kevin. I'm with Kevin. Are you kidding me? Yeah, Kevin's not having it.
而现在吉姆说他单身。帕姆有一个采访镜头，她说，哦，是的，我们出去吃了几次饭。我们谈论了他的分手，但我们只是好朋友。能再次成为朋友真是太好了。好吧，我和凯文站在一起。我和凯文站在一起。你在开玩笑吗？是的，凯文不买账。
This was also a fun talking head for Kevin and Oscar, because it starts with Kevin and then reveals Oscar when Kevin's like, right? And he's like, well, there's no evidence of intimacy. And, you know, but they are both in very good moods. We had a couple of fan questions about this plot point. Okay. Julia Johnson and Madeline Nelson noticed Pam has a big change to her hair and wardrobe. Is it because she's dating Jim now?
这对凯文和奥斯卡来说也是一个有趣的采访镜头，因为它从凯文开始，然后在凯文说“对吧？”时揭示了奥斯卡。他说，嗯，没有亲密的证据。而且，你知道，但他们心情都很好。我们有几个关于这个情节点的粉丝问题。好的。朱莉娅·约翰逊和玛德琳·尼尔森注意到帕姆的发型和服装有很大的变化。是因为她现在在和吉姆约会吗？
And was there a lot of discussion about these changes? Oh, yes. Well, her hair is very different. Yes, no more clipped back hair. Crunchy hair. Yes, this change was a huge discussion. Pam is also not wearing her traditional button-down shirt and her little cardigan. She's wearing this cutesy little sweater with a little kind of bow that ties on the side.
关于这些变化有很多讨论吗？哦，是的。嗯，她的头发非常不同。是的，不再是夹起来的头发了。脆脆的头发。是的，这个变化是一个巨大的讨论。帕姆也没有穿她传统的纽扣衬衫和她的小开衫。她穿着这件可爱的毛衣，侧面系着一个小蝴蝶结。
A very, very flirtatious shade of beige. I noticed that too. I was like, well, we didn't go too far. Yeah. Get me the cutest beige sweater you can find. Well, it was a big discussion. We couldn't have this giant transformation. Greg did not want that moment from those movies where the sort of nerdy girl with the glasses
一种非常、非常调情的米色。我也注意到了。我想，好吧，我们没有走得太远。是的。给我找一件你能找到的最可爱的米色毛衣。好吧，这是一个很大的讨论。我们不能有那种巨大的转变。格雷格不想要那些电影里的那种时刻，那种戴眼镜的书呆子女孩
falls in love. And then after she falls in love, she's got a gorgeous blowout and doesn't need her glasses anymore. You know, that whole story that we saw a million times growing up? It was called Kelly Kapoor. It was called Kelly Kapoor. You can only do that with one character. So we met our limit.
坠入爱河。然后在她坠入爱河后，她有了一个华丽的吹发造型，不再需要眼镜了。你知道，我们从小看了无数遍的那个故事？它叫凯莉·卡普尔。它叫凯莉·卡普尔。你只能对一个角色这样做。所以我们达到了极限。
But we did imagine that this new relationship would possibly affect Pam and how she looked and her desire to make an effort that maybe she didn't have a desire to make before. I get this. I mean, don't you remember Angela in your young love phases with someone knew that your date, You give a little extra juz, right? Yeah, of course. We had a big fan catch regarding Pam's wardrobe. This came from Megan Robinson, Steph Baldwin, Laura Roaldon, Haley McMurdy, and Kelly Ann Mim.
但我们确实想象过，这种新的关系可能会影响帕姆以及她的外表，以及她想要做出努力的愿望，也许她以前没有这种愿望。我明白这一点。我的意思是，安吉拉，你不记得你在年轻恋爱阶段和某人在一起时，你会多一点点活力，对吧？是的，当然。我们有一个关于帕姆服装的大粉丝发现。这来自梅根·罗宾逊、斯蒂芬·鲍德温、劳拉·罗尔登、海莉·麦克默迪和凯利·安·米姆。
They all noticed that Pam's necklace changes in this episode. You know what it is now? What? She's a butterfly. Fly, butterfly. You're not that worm anymore. Fly. No.
他们都注意到帕姆的项链在这一集中变了。你知道现在是什么吗？什么？她是只蝴蝶。飞吧，蝴蝶。你不再是那条虫子了。飞吧。不。
I think you mean caterpillar. Caterpillar. Squishy thing. You're not that squid. You're a beautiful flying in the wind. Yes, she has metamorphosized into a beautiful butterfly. That's right. No longer the unicorn.
我想你是说毛毛虫。毛毛虫。软乎乎的东西。你不是那只鱿鱼。你是一只在风中飞舞的美丽蝴蝶。是的，她已经蜕变成了一只美丽的蝴蝶。没错。不再是独角兽了。
Now the butterfly. Jim and Pam at three minutes are discussing their separate weekend plans in front of Kevin. It's making him crazy, right? Because he's not buying it. Yep. Pam says, you know, maybe she'll go to the flea market at the drive-in. Guys, I'll look this up. There is a flea market at an old drive-in.
现在是蝴蝶。吉姆和帕姆在三分钟时正在凯文面前讨论他们各自的周末计划。这让他发疯，对吧？因为他不相信。是的。帕姆说，你知道，也许她会去汽车影院的跳蚤市场。伙计们，我查过了。在一个旧的汽车影院确实有一个跳蚤市场。
And it was actually the Reader's Choice Award for Best Flea Market. It's located at the famous Circle Drive-In in the Circle Flea Fair. It's the largest flea market and farmers market in northeastern Pennsylvania. So that is 100% believable. that Pam would be going. Yes. And Jim says he's going to go mountain biking at Montage Mountain. Well, I look that up.
它实际上是读者选择奖的最佳跳蚤市场。它位于著名的Circle Drive-In的Circle Flea Fair。它是宾夕法尼亚州东北部最大的跳蚤市场和农贸市场。所以帕姆会去那里是100%可信的。是的。吉姆说他要去Montage Mountain骑山地自行车。好吧，我查过了。
And correct me if I'm wrong, folks in Pennsylvania. But Montage Mountain has, you know, ski runs, but you can't mountain bike on it. Unless there's some trails I don't know about. I actually found an online petition from April of 2019 of folks wanting to mountain bike on Montage Mountain, but you can't. And there's an online petition because people want to. Wow. Sorry.
如果我错了，请纠正我，宾夕法尼亚州的伙计们。但Montage Mountain有，你知道，滑雪道，但你不能在那里骑山地自行车。除非有一些我不知道的小径。我实际上发现了一个2019年4月的在线请愿书，人们想要在Montage Mountain骑山地自行车，但你不能。而且有一个在线请愿书，因为人们想要。哇。抱歉。
I'm sorry. Had to do a local deep dive. Well, you know what? Perhaps that's the evidence that Jim and Pam are not actually having separate plans that weekend. Hmm. Because he would know. If Kevin knew that there was no mountain biking on Montage Mountain, he would know. Kevin doesn't know that because he's not athletic.
抱歉。不得不做一个本地深度挖掘。好吧，你知道吗？也许这就是吉姆和帕姆那个周末实际上没有分开计划的证据。嗯。因为他会知道的。如果凯文知道Montage Mountain没有山地自行车，他会知道的。凯文不知道，因为他不爱运动。
No. But Jim knows. that. Jim got it wrong. Well, now Michael arrives and he breaks the news that Meredith has been hit by a car. Yeah. Yeah. You know, luckily he was there. Yeah. And he drove her to the hospital. He said the doctors did the best they could. They did everything they could to save her life. And she's going to be okay. Yeah. And Stanley's like, why the hell would you say it like that? Who talks like that?
不。但吉姆知道。那个。吉姆弄错了。好吧，现在迈克尔到了，他带来了梅雷迪思被车撞的消息。是的。是的。幸运的是他在那里。是的。他开车送她去了医院。他说医生尽了最大努力。他们尽了一切努力挽救她的生命。她会没事的。是的。斯坦利说，你为什么要那样说？谁会那样说话？
It's so good. I love that line from Stanley so much. Leslie is so good in that delivery. He's so good. And I loved it when Andy's like, well, who hit her? And then Michael's like, kind of a good news, bad news there. I was able to be on the scene so quickly because I I was in the car that hit her.
太好了。我非常喜欢斯坦利的那句台词。莱斯利的表达太棒了。他太棒了。我喜欢安迪说，嗯，谁撞了她？然后迈克尔说，好消息，坏消息。我能这么快到达现场是因为我，我就是撞她的那辆车。
And Jim's like, oh, no. Yeah, Jim's like, who was driving the car. And that's what Pam is like. Oh, Michael. Oh, Michael. At four minutes, four seconds, there's a reaction shot of everyone. And the accountants are all sort of standing together. Guys, the return of the fluffy blouse.
吉姆说，哦，不。是的，吉姆说，谁在开车。这就是帕姆说，哦，迈克尔。哦，迈克尔。在四分零四秒，有一个每个人的反应镜头。会计们都站在一起。伙计们，蓬松衬衫的回归。
Oh, is it a fluffy blouse in an accountant's stack? It's a floofy blouse and an accountant clump. This is more of a clump than a stack. All right. But Jenna, you can also see that over the summer I got bangs. Oh. Yes. And Kim Ferry had to try to style my hair.
哦，那是会计堆里的蓬松衬衫吗？那是一件蓬松的衬衫，在一个会计堆里。这更像是一堆而不是一叠。好的。但是珍娜，你也可以看到夏天我留了刘海。哦。是的。金·费里不得不尝试打理我的头发。
But I think I have sort of stylish bangs. Oh. Yeah. Well, there you go. I know. Well, now we are moving into Michael's office. Dwight is trying to make Michael feel better by explaining it's going to be fine. I mean, it's only marriage.
但我认为我有那种时髦的刘海。哦。是的。好吧，就是这样。我知道。好吧，现在我们进入迈克尔的办公室。德怀特试图通过解释一切都会好起来让迈克尔感觉好点。我的意思是，这只是婚姻。
But Michael is upset because he thinks everyone thinks he might be a murderer. Or they were looking at him like he was a murderer. Can you imagine if some of the writers had had their way? I know. No kidding. Gosh. Well, now Pam is going to go around the office. She thinks everyone should visit Meredith and she's collecting money so they can buy her flowers.
但迈克尔很沮丧，因为他认为每个人都认为他可能是个杀人犯。或者他们看着他就像他是个杀人犯一样。你能想象如果一些编剧得逞了会怎样吗？我知道。别开玩笑了。天哪。好吧，现在帕姆要绕着办公室走。她认为每个人都应该去探望梅雷迪思，她正在筹钱买花。
Yes, but Angela says she can't go because Sprinkles is sick. Mm-hmm. And Angela needs to go home at least. lunch to give sprinkles some medicine and eat lunch with her cat. Yeah. And you guys, there are wonderful deleted talking heads from this episode. So many characters have great talking heads. But this is a talking head that would have happened right before Pam walked over to
是的，但安吉拉说她不能去，因为Sprinkles病了。嗯。安吉拉需要回家，至少午餐时间要给Sprinkles喂药，并和她的猫一起吃午餐。是的，伙计们，这一集有很棒的删减采访镜头。很多角色都有很棒的采访镜头。但这本来是一个在帕姆走到安吉拉面前之前发生的采访镜头。
Angela. And I have to read it to you because it's so fun to me. Angela has a talking head that says, I've had sprinkles for 16 years. I adopted her when I graduated from accounting school. I knew the kind of life I wanted. One with the companionship and unpredictable good times only a cat offers. The unpredictable good times a cat offers. You know, cats really do offer unpredictable good times.
我必须读给你听，因为它对我来说太有趣了。安吉拉有一个采访镜头，说，我养Sprinkles 16年了。我从会计学校毕业时收养了她。我知道我想要什么样的生活。一种只有猫才能提供的陪伴和不可预测的美好时光。猫提供的不可预测的美好时光。你知道，猫确实提供了不可预测的美好时光。
Creed Bratton has texted me this sentence. An unpredictable good time only a cat offers. Creed texted me that the other day. I love that. So, yes. So Angela has that talking head and that you didn't get to see. And it really sort of builds up like, this is like more than a cat to her. I mean, we already know that.
克里德·布拉顿给我发短信说了这句话。只有猫才能提供的不可预测的美好时光。克里德前几天给我发了短信。我喜欢那个。所以，是的。所以安吉拉有那个你没看到的采访镜头。它确实建立了一种感觉，就像，这对她来说不仅仅是一只猫。我的意思是，我们已经知道了。
But when Pam suggests that Angela, like, should go and that she's, like, ditching on her party planning committee duties, Angela's ticked. Uh, Sam, can I get a Pam sass? Pam sass. Yeah. We had some people write in, Paige Banker, Lauren Corwin. They just wrote in all caps, major Pam Sass at five minutes, 35 seconds. Yeah, I agree, you guys. Pam, Pam says, can't your other cats keep her company?
但当帕姆建议安吉拉应该去，而且她在“逃避”她的派对策划委员会职责时，安吉拉被激怒了。嗯，萨姆，我能来一段帕姆的刻薄吗？帕姆的刻薄。是的。我们有一些人写信来，佩奇·班克、劳伦·科温。他们只是用大写字母写道，五分三十五秒时帕姆的重大刻薄。是的，我同意，伙计们。帕姆说，你的其他猫不能陪她吗？
And Angela's like, there's bad blood, jealousies, clicks. What's happening at this woman's house? I have to tell you something about this scene. This was what I thought you were going to tell me when you said that I had written you an email about this episode. Why? And about what I was doing this week. Why?
安吉拉说，有积怨、嫉妒、小团体。这个女人的家里发生了什么？我必须告诉你关于这个场景的一些事情。这就是当你告诉我你给我发了一封关于这一集的邮件时，我以为你要告诉我的。为什么？关于我这一周在做什么。为什么？
Lady, I was really, really hungover when we shot this scene. Like, super hungover. And if you look at me in this scene, compared to every other scene, you can see it on my face. I am like, I am gray. I'm kind of green. Why? My eyes are puffy.
女士，拍这个场景时我真的，真的宿醉了。就像，超级宿醉。如果你在这个场景中看我，和其他场景相比，你可以在我的脸上看到它。我像，我是灰色的。我有点绿。为什么？我的眼睛肿了。
I will never forget it. So, the night before this shoot, I went to a Mexican restaurant and I was with a friend who ordered a margarita. Okay. I had never really had a margarita before. Oh, no way. Yes, yes, it's true. We've talked about this.
我永远不会忘记它。所以，拍摄前一天晚上，我去了墨西哥餐厅，我和一个点玛格丽塔的朋友在一起。好的。我以前从来没喝过玛格丽塔。哦，不会吧。是的，是的，这是真的。我们谈过这个。
I did not have a lot of experience with drinking. I just, you know, I had a cosmopolitan. I had to research drinking in order to play drunk Pam. So I took a sip of it. Yeah. And I was like, this is delicious. I love this drink. Uh-oh.
我没有太多喝酒的经验。我只是，你知道，我喝过大都会。为了扮演喝醉的帕姆，我不得不研究喝酒。所以我喝了一口。是的。我想，这太好吃了。我喜欢这种饮料。哦，不。
And then I had three. Three? Three over the course of this dinner. Jenna. I then, you know, lady, this scene was the first scene of the next day. We had a super early call time and I was really feeling it. Like I didn't, I had not had enough time to recover from my three margaritas. Oh yeah. My call times were routinely like 5 a.m. 5.30. So you were, you were sweating tequila. I was. And so I thought when you said earlier that you had to. an email from me about what I was doing this week. I was like, oh my gosh, did I write Angela about those margaritas? Sorry to disappoint. You had a mandatory physical table read and a sexual harassment seminar. Exactly. Anyway, that's my little tidbit. Every time I see this scene, I'm reminded of the
然后我喝了三杯。三杯？在晚餐过程中喝了三杯。珍娜。然后，你知道，女士，这个场景是第二天第一个场景。我们有超级早的通告时间，我真的感觉到了。就像我没有，我没有足够的时间从我的三杯玛格丽塔中恢复过来。哦，是的。我的通告时间通常是早上5点，5点半。所以你在冒龙舌兰酒的汗。我是。所以我以为你之前说你有一封我的邮件关于我这一周在做什么。我想，哦，天哪，我写信给安吉拉说那些玛格丽塔了吗？抱歉让你失望了。你有一个强制性的体检、剧本围读和性骚扰研讨会。完全正确。无论如何，这是我的小花絮。每次我看到这个场景，我都会想起
night that I first drank three margaritas. Well, now I'll always remember it. So now Michael has to call Ryan, because Ryan is his boss and tell him he hit Meredith on company property. With his company car. Yeah. And Ryan is such a badass boss in this. He's clearly, he's like and being the boss in talking to Michael this way. Well, and then we go to the Ryan talking head and Ryan has a new look. He's got his like, his, what do you call that?
我第一次喝三杯玛格丽塔的那个晚上。好吧，现在我会永远记住它。所以现在迈克尔必须给瑞恩打电话，因为瑞恩是他的老板，告诉他他在公司财产上撞了梅雷迪思。用他的公司车。是的。瑞恩在这个场景中是一个非常强硬的老板。他显然，他就像，作为老板以这种方式和迈克尔交谈。好吧，然后我们进入瑞恩的采访镜头，瑞恩有一个新造型。他有他的，你叫那个什么？
It's not a beard. It's like a, the permanent stubble. Yeah, it's like a five o'clock shadow, but it's a choice. It's a choice. Yeah. Yeah. And his hair's all slicked back. He's got like kind of a Gordon Gecko thing going on.
这不是胡子。这就像，永久的胡茬。是的，这就像五点钟的阴影，但这是一个选择。这是一个选择。是的。是的。他的头发都向后梳了。他有一种戈登·盖柯的感觉。
Yeah. He looks like he should be in the show succession. That's what he looks like. Yes. Right? And he has the same kind of like cheesy attitude. He's like, some people keep calling me, you know, Wonder Kid, you know, not really sure what that means. Well, I guess I do know what it means.
是的。他看起来应该在《继承之战》里。他看起来就是那样。是的。对吧？他有同样那种俗气的态度。他说，有些人一直叫我，你知道，神童，你知道，不太确定那是什么意思。好吧，我想我知道那是什么意思。
He's, oh, it's so cringy. Yeah, it's great. This is, we're going to get a glimpse now of what this new dynamic is going to be like. Well, then we have a scene that I love Angela because it's a Dwight and Angela secret scene. Remember, the people in the office, we don't know you're dating, right? So you guys are still kind of like a secret couple. Whenever you want to talk to each other, you have to go be like weirdly secretive about it. Yeah.
他，哦，太让人尴尬了。是的，太棒了。这是，我们现在要一窥这种新动态会是什么样子。好吧，然后我们有一个我喜欢的场景，安吉拉，因为这是一个德怀特和安吉拉的秘密场景。记住，办公室里的人，我们不知道你们在约会，对吧？所以你们仍然是那种秘密情侣。每当你们想互相交谈时，你们都必须表现得非常神秘。是的。
I mean, I guess only Jim knows, right? And Pam. Have Jim and Pam hopefully talked about it at this point? We still don't know. You would think. So, lady, I had a long speech where I talk about all of Sprinkles medications, and I did that thing like you did on beach games. I learned it backwards and forward so that I could say it just effortlessly, you know? But here it is.
我的意思是，我想只有吉姆知道，对吧？还有帕姆。吉姆和帕姆此时希望已经谈过这件事了吗？我们仍然不知道。你会这么想。所以，女士，我有一段很长的演讲，我谈到了Sprinkles所有的药物，我做了像你在海滩游戏上做的那样。我把它背得滚瓜烂熟，这样我就能毫不费力地说出来，你知道吗？但就是这里。
Sam, can you play that clip? So what do you need me to do? I wrote it out. There's a diabetes shot. Roll the insulin in your hands. Don't shake it. She gets an ACE inhibitor with her meal. If you have to put her right in front of the dish
萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？那么你需要我做什么？我写下来了。有糖尿病注射。在手里滚动胰岛素。不要摇晃它。她随餐服用ACE抑制剂。如果你必须把她放在盘子前面
or she won't see it because of the cataracts. Mix one capsule of omega fatty acid in with her kidney medicine. And you want to give that to her 15 minutes after she's eaten. And, oh, there's a fungal cream because she has this infection under her tail. So you're going to have to lift her tail and put the cream right at the base of her tail. I love that you memorized it, Angela, because when I watched that, I wondered. I thought the answer was yes because you delivered it like you knew. And if you had a cat that was sick, you would know, right?
否则她因为白内障看不到它。混合一粒欧米茄脂肪酸胶囊和她的肾脏药物。你想在她吃完饭15分钟后给她。而且，哦，有一种真菌霜，因为她的尾巴下面有这种感染。所以你必须抬起她的尾巴，把药膏涂在尾巴根部。我喜欢你把它背下来，安吉拉，因为当我看到那个时，我很好奇。我以为答案是肯定的，因为你表达得就像你知道一样。如果你有一只生病的猫，你会知道，对吧？
You wouldn't be searching for that information. You would know it. Oh, yeah. And they had, the props department had given me this blue notepad with all of the different steps written out, but not in the same order. Not exactly. So, like, actually, if I looked at the notepad, it would have messed me up. But I saved the notepad with all of Sprinkles medications. and it's the one I hand Dwight in the scene.
你不会去搜索那个信息。你会知道的。哦，是的。而且他们有，道具部门给了我这个蓝色的记事本，上面写着所有不同的步骤，但顺序不一样。不完全是。所以，就像，实际上，如果我看了记事本，它会把我搞乱。但我保存了记事本，上面有Sprinkles所有的药物。而且这就是我在场景中交给德怀特的那本。
He's holding it. I saved it. I never tore off that first page and I still have it. And the whole notepad is unused. And that first page just has all of sprinkles like medicines and how to care for her. Oh, my gosh. Oh, look. Oh, wait.
他拿着它。我保存了它。我从来没有撕掉第一页，而且我还留着它。整本记事本都没用过。第一页只是有Sprinkles所有的药物以及如何照顾她。天哪。哦，看。哦，等等。
Oh, I took a picture of it. Do you want to see? Yeah. Okay, here. That is amazing. But that's not your handwriting. No, no, no. It's not my handwriting.
哦，我拍了一张照片。你想看吗？是的。好的，给你。那太棒了。但那不是你的笔迹。不，不，不。那不是我的笔迹。
Someone in the props department wrote that out. Wow. We have to post that on the pod. We'll post it on the pod. Okay. Sprinkles medication going on the pod. Well, we got a fan question from Tracy Prescott, who said this. I am a cat-focused veterinarian in Atlanta, and I was wondering if an actual doctor of veterinary medicine was consulted about Sprinkles's medical needs because Angela's list of medications and treatments she gave to Dwight were very realistic. Oh, that's fantastic. Well, Greg told me that he had the writer's assistants, Nate Federman and Jonathan Hughes, do research into the accurate cat medicines.
道具部门的某个人写下来的。哇。我们必须把它发到播客上。我们会把它发到播客上。好的。Sprinkles的药物要发到播客上。好吧，我们收到了特雷西·普雷斯科特的一个粉丝问题，她说这个。我是一名专注于猫的兽医，在亚特兰大，我想知道是否咨询过真正的兽医博士关于Sprinkles的医疗需求，因为安吉拉给德怀特的药物和治疗清单非常现实。哦，那太棒了。好吧，格雷格告诉我，他让编剧助理内特·费德曼和乔纳森·休斯对准确的猫药进行了研究。
And that is why that list of medicines is so realistic. Well, good job, writers assistants. That's right. Well, listen, before we go on, maybe we should take a break because coming up, Michael is going to try to, I don't know, write this wrong. He's going to try. It's not going to go well. It never does. No. All right. We'll be back. We are back and Angela Michael has gone into the break room in an attempt to rally everyone to plant a tree in honor of Meredith. But do you know what I titled this scene? You are always titling scenes and I have titled a scene. What? John eats popcorn. Oh my gosh.
这就是为什么那份药物清单如此真实。好吧，干得好，编剧助理们。没错。好了，听着，在我们继续之前，也许我们应该休息一下，因为接下来，迈克尔要尝试，我不知道，去纠正这个错误。他会尝试的。这不会顺利的。从来没顺利过。不。好吧。我们会回来的。我们回来了，安吉拉，迈克尔去了休息室，试图召集大家为梅雷迪思种一棵树。但你知道我给这个场景起了什么标题吗？你总是给场景起标题，而我给一个场景起了标题。什么？约翰在吃爆米花。天哪。
Did you notice he is eating popcorn through this whole scene? Not carrots, not baby carrots, but popcorn. And the way he's eating it, it's so delicate. Was he trying not to crunch too loudly? I think he was trying not to be a problem for sound, but he was clearly hungry because he eats it through the whole scene. Oh my God. Was this the year we got that little popcorn maker by craft services? It must have been. This must have been the first week with the popcorn makeup.
你注意到他在整个场景中都在吃爆米花吗？不是胡萝卜，不是小胡萝卜，而是爆米花。他吃它的方式，太优雅了。他是在尽量不发出太大的咀嚼声吗？我想他是在尽量不给录音造成麻烦，但他显然饿了，因为他在整个场景中都在吃。天哪。这是我们从后勤服务处拿到那个小爆米花机的那一年吗？一定是。这一定是爆米花机出现的第一周。
We went a little crazy for popcorn. And then the sound department, I think, said, okay, guys. I remember it went away. Yeah. But we were excited about it. Well, he's eating popcorn in this whole scene. And it's also in this scene that Pam explains to Michael, you know, we're just going to go visit Meredith. We're going in shift so we don't overwhelm her.
我们对爆米花有点疯狂。然后录音部门，我想，说，好了，伙计们。我记得它后来消失了。是的。但我们当时很兴奋。好吧，他在整个场景中都在吃爆米花。也是在这个场景中，帕姆向迈克尔解释说，你知道，我们只是要去探望梅雷迪思。我们轮流去，这样就不会让她不知所措。
But Michael is like, no, we're all going together. At the same time, I'll drive. So Jim and Pam are like, well, we can each take people in our separate cars. And Oscar's like, separate cars. And Kevin's like, I don't believe it. I know. Well, then Michael has a talking head and he says, you know, I have flaws, you know, so sue me. And he's like, no, no, no, don't sue me.
但迈克尔说，不，我们要一起去。同时，我来开车。所以吉姆和帕姆说，好吧，我们可以各自开车带人。奥斯卡说，分开的车。凯文说，我不相信。我知道。好吧，然后迈克尔有一个独白，他说，你知道，我有缺点，你知道，去告我吧。然后他说，不，不，不，别告我。
But Jenna, there was an alt to this talking head. And it's in the deleted scenes. And it made me laugh so hard. And it's also in the bloopers. And Steve couldn't get through it. He kept laughing. What is it? Okay, this is it.
但是珍娜，这个独白有一个替代版本。它在删减片段里。它让我笑得好厉害。它也在花絮里。史蒂夫没法演完。他一直在笑。是什么？好吧，就是这个。
There's one take, clearly he got through it because it's in the deleted scenes. He says, I am not a bad guy. I am a good guy who runs over women with his car. Why am I having such a hard time getting my message across? Oh my gosh, that is funny. And the way Steve does it is so good. That's good. I have to go watch that.
有一个镜头，显然他演完了，因为它在删减片段里。他说，我不是个坏人。我是个好人，只是开车撞倒了女人。为什么我这么难把我的意思表达清楚？天哪，那太搞笑了。史蒂夫演出的方式太棒了。那很好。我得去看看那个。
Yeah, you have to. Well, we don't find out exactly. exactly how they get there, but the entire gang does arrive at the hospital. Michael has a whole bunch of balloons. And the entire gang minus Dwight. That's right, because Dwight has gone to take care of sprinkles. Everyone gathers around Meredith's bed, and we talked about this scene with Kate about how Steve improvised crawling on top of her in that one moment. He's like trying to give her a hug.
是的，你必须去。好吧，我们不知道他们具体是怎么到达那里的，但整群人都到了医院。迈克尔带了一大堆气球。除了德怀特，整群人都到了。没错，因为德怀特去照顾斯普林克尔斯了。大家都聚集在梅雷迪思的床边，我们和凯特谈过这个场景，关于史蒂夫在那一刻即兴爬到她身上。他试图给她一个拥抱。
It's pretty amazing. It's pretty great. There is a deleted scene from this moment where Creed, as they're exiting, just grabs all her meds out of the little plastic cups. They're sitting on her tray. Oh. And Creed just pockets all her meds. Of course he does. Well, I had a favorite moment from the scene, and I wanted to ask you about it because I think maybe you improvised it.
这太神奇了。这太棒了。这个时刻有一个删减片段，克里德在他们离开时，直接从塑料杯里抓走了她所有的药。它们放在她的托盘上。哦。克里德直接把她所有的药装进了口袋。他当然会这么做。好吧，我有一个这个场景中最喜欢的时刻，我想问你，因为我觉得也许是你即兴发挥的。
When Michael is trying to get Meredith to forgive him, he says that she should think about the Bible. because it says that forgiveness is next to godliness. And you mutter, that's cleanliness. I did improvise that. Oh, I also wanted to mention in this scene, The Nurse, who is an improv person from I.O. Her name is Sylvia McClure. Well, I looked at her IMDB, and I found this very interesting.
当迈克尔试图让梅雷迪思原谅他时，他说她应该想想圣经。因为它说宽恕仅次于神圣。而你嘟囔说，那是清洁。那是我即兴发挥的。哦，我还想提一下这个场景中的护士，她是一个来自I.O.的即兴表演者。她的名字叫西尔维亚·麦克卢尔。好吧，我查了她的IMDB，我发现这非常有趣。
In addition to playing a nurse on the office, she has also played a doctor on Young and the Restless, Dexter and Intelligence, a nurse in Night of the Dead, and a receptionist nurse on the unit. So she's played a lot of nurses and doctors. And incidentally, she's also twice been cast as a nun. That is very interesting, like sort of a, it's like a weird typecasting. Yeah, exactly. Well, I used to get a lot of auditions for school teachers.
除了在《办公室》里扮演护士，她还在《不安的青春》、《嗜血法医》和《智能》中扮演过医生，在《死亡之夜》中扮演过护士，在《急诊室的故事》中扮演过接待护士。所以她扮演过很多护士和医生。顺便说一句，她还两次被选为修女。这非常有趣，就像一种奇怪的类型化选角。是的，完全正确。好吧，我过去常接到很多关于学校老师的试镜。
and nurses. Have you ever played a nurse or doctor? Yes, actually, I played a pediatric nurse in this movie called The Promotion. I played a doctor on an episode of Monk, and I played a sexy nurse briefly in one of our Halloween episodes of the office. What were you most often typecast as for auditions? Before the office. before the office. Quirky. Quarky gal. What's up? My quirky,
和护士。你演过护士或医生吗？是的，实际上，我在一部叫《晋升》的电影里演过儿科护士。我在《神探阿蒙》的一集里演过医生，我在《办公室》的万圣节剧集里短暂地演过性感护士。你在试镜中最常被定型为什么角色？在《办公室》之前。在《办公室》之前。古怪的。古怪的女孩。怎么了？我的古怪，
quirky fun neighbor? Quirky neighbor. Yeah. But I was, I got a lot of just the school teachers, waitresses, and nurses. Well, I will tell you, we talked about how hard we laughed in this scene, but 11 minutes, 22 seconds is when you can see us breaking. If you're looking for it, that's when Michael crawls on top of Meredith. Well, now we can go back to the office and we are going to find Dwight telling Angela some bad news. And she's anxious to see him.
古怪有趣的邻居？古怪的邻居。是的。但我确实接到了很多学校老师、女服务员和护士的角色。好吧，我会告诉你，我们谈过在这个场景中我们笑得有多厉害，但在11分22秒时你可以看到我们笑场了。如果你在找它，那就是迈克尔爬到梅雷迪思身上的时候。好吧，现在我们可以回到办公室了，我们要看到德怀特告诉安吉拉一些坏消息。她很急切地想见到他。
She wants to know how it went. You can just tell. And then he's like, hey, monkey. And she's like, any problems? Well, you left the TV on and your cat is dead. And my character's like, what? And he's like, sparkles. The white one is dead.
她想知道结果如何。你一眼就能看出来。然后他说，嘿，猴子。她说，有什么问题吗？好吧，你没关电视，你的猫死了。我的角色说，什么？他说，斯帕克尔斯。那只白色的死了。
Yeah, he gets the name wrong. It's bad. It is bad. This will not end well. Angela, you get so very immediately emotional and not in a funny way. Like, this is one of the ways that our show allowed characters to be real people because Angela, the character really loved her cat, and she is heartbroken. And you see that real pain here from your character.
是的，他把名字叫错了。这很糟糕。这真的很糟糕。这不会有好结果的。安吉拉，你立刻变得非常情绪化，而且不是以一种有趣的方式。就像，这是我们的剧集允许角色成为真实人物的方式之一，因为安吉拉这个角色真的很爱她的猫，她心碎了。你在这里看到了你角色真实的痛苦。
How did you gear up for this scene? Well, Greg told me he said, you know, Angela Martin, hearing this news will be devastated. And I need you to play out the beats of hearing news that kind of destroys you in the moment. You know, and I feel like we've all had moments in our lives where we've gotten that phone call with some bad news, you know, unfortunately. And I just sort of thought about a few of those moments where, you know, at first you're just in total shock. where you're not really sure what you heard. Yeah.
你是如何为这个场景做准备的？好吧，格雷格告诉我，他说，你知道，安吉拉·马丁听到这个消息会崩溃的。我需要你表现出听到那种让你瞬间崩溃的消息时的节奏。你知道，我觉得我们生活中都有过接到坏消息电话的时刻，你知道，不幸的是。我只是想了想其中的几个时刻，你知道，起初你完全处于震惊中。你不太确定你听到了什么。是的。
And then it's like someone slaps you in the face with the information. And then you're trying to make sense of it, but you can't make sense of it. It's the unthinkable. And it doesn't make sense. And your body is doing all of that. You're in shock. You're sad. Your body, your mind is trying to make it right, but you can't make it right.
然后就像有人给了你一记耳光。然后你试图理解它，但你无法理解。这是不可想象的。这说不通。你的身体正在经历这一切。你处于震惊中。你很伤心。你的身体，你的思想试图让它变好，但你无法让它变好。
You can't figure it out. You don't understand why it happened. And I was just trying to process through all. of that. And yeah, that's what I did. Did you have to do a lot of takes of that scene? Do you remember? No, I didn't. I was thankful for that. In the next scene, your character is still crying. She's standing at reception with Pam and you look like you've been crying for a long time. What did you do to get there to start the scene in a place like that? You know, I'm chatty. So my instinct would be, I'm standing by reception with you would be to be hanging.
你无法弄清楚。你不明白为什么会发生这种情况。我只是试图处理所有这些。是的，这就是我做的。你拍这个场景拍了很多次吗？你记得吗？不，没有。我很感激这一点。在下一个场景中，你的角色还在哭。她站在接待处和帕姆在一起，你看上去已经哭了很长时间了。你是怎么做到进入那个状态，在那样的地方开始这个场景的？你知道，我很健谈。所以我的本能会是，我和你站在接待处会是闲逛，你知道，成为办公室的一部分。所以，我做的一件事是在拍摄间隙独自走到电梯拐角处，我没有闲逛。我只是试图保持那种悲伤的空间。而且化妆部门，他们希望我的眼睛看起来真的像我大哭过一场。他们做到了。所以我必须让自己回到那种情绪中，再次变得悲伤。而且化妆部门，肯尼斯·保罗，给我化妆的人，用了那种眼线笔，真的让内部。就像在你眼睛内部，红粉色。所以我的眼睛，我的眼睛看起来很像，然后在情感上我做到了。你的眼睛看起来像你昨天喝了三杯玛格丽特。你看起来就是那样。也许那就是我，那应该是我
out, you know, being part of the bullpen. So one of the things I did was I went around the corner by the elevators by myself in between takes and I did not hang out. And I just tried to stay in sort of that sad space. And also the makeup department, they wanted my eyes to really look like I had bawled my eyes out. And they did. So I had to get myself back in that emotional place and get sad again. And also the makeup department, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup, did like this type of eyeliner that really made the inside. It was like in the inside of your eye, reddish pink. So my eyes, my eyes looked the part and then emotionally I got there. Your eyes looked like you had three margaritas yesterday. That's what you look like. Maybe that's what I, that should have been my
准备工作，而不是眼线和悲伤的想法。是的。不。发生的事情是拉弗恩只是给肯尼斯·保罗看了我前一天的一张照片，说，让她看起来像那样。不，但说真的，安吉拉，当我看到这一系列你的角色对斯普林克尔斯的死感到非常非常崩溃的场景时，我真的对你的表演、你的范围和你的可信度印象深刻。这真是太棒了，太棒的工作了。哦，谢谢。我很感激。我真的很感激格雷格为我写了这个故事情节，我得以做所有这些事情，你知道吗？而且，你知道，他作为导演的方针总是尽量保持真实。是的。好吧，这个场景中还有另一个非常棒的时刻，我们确实有一位粉丝写信来。凯蒂·哈威克说，我认为我们需要给迈克尔点个赞。当安吉拉的猫死的时候。他不仅知道它的名字，而且还沉浸在悲伤中。他非常关心他的员工，对我来说这是一个非常甜蜜的时刻。但我确实得问，
prep instead of eyeliner and sad thoughts. Yeah. No. What happened was Laverne just showed Kenneth Paul a picture of me from the previous day and was like, make her look like that. No, but in all seriousness, Angela, when I was watching these series of scenes where your character is really, really devastated over the death of sprinkles, I was just so beyond impressed with your performance and your range and your believability. It was just, this is just great, great work. Oh, thanks. I appreciate that. I really appreciated Greg writing the storyline for me, and I got to do all these things, you know? And, you know, his take as a director was always to try to keep it as honest as possible. Yeah. Well, there's another really great moment in this scene, and we actually had a fan right in. Katie Harwick said, I think we need to give a shout out to Michael. when Angela's cat dies. Not only did he know her name, but he was overcome with grief. He cares so much for his employees, and it was just such a sweet moment to me. But I do have to ask,
你认为他是真的难过，还是他只是把这看作是一个可以分散大家注意力，不去谈论撞到梅雷迪思的话题？我个人认为他为斯普林克尔斯感到非常心烦意乱。好吧，我同意。这发生在12分41秒，这是我最喜欢的迈克尔令人动容的时刻之一。现在，也许是因为这对我来说很个人，因为，你知道，我扮演了安吉拉·马丁。我知道她有多爱她的猫。但迈克尔，就像那些不给糖就捣蛋的孩子来到他家，你看到他的喜悦的那一刻。就像他出现在帕姆的艺术展上的那一刻。迈克尔真的把这些人看作他的家人。所以迈克尔知道安吉拉对斯普林克尔斯的爱。他当然知道。
do you think he was truly sad, or did he just see this as a distraction from hitting Meredith that everyone could talk about instead? I personally think he was very distraught about sprinkles. Well, I agree. This happens at 12 minutes' 41 seconds, and it is one of my favorite, endearing moments of Michael. Now, maybe because it's personal for me, because, you know, I played Angela Martin. I knew how much she loved her cats. But Michael, it's like that moment when the trick-or-treaters come to his house and you see his joy. It's like that moment when he shows up to Pam's art show. Michael really saw these people as his family. So Michael knew Angela's love of sprinkles. Of course he did.
听到斯普林克尔斯死了，他很难过。他把手放在脸上，靠在墙上，他说，哦，该死。对不起，安吉拉。我的意思是，还能更糟吗？他感受到了这一切。他真的感到很难过。现在他第一次把斯普林克尔斯的名字叫对了。然后他发表了一大通演讲，叫它普林克尔斯。
And he was gutted to hear that Sprinkles died. The way he puts his hand up to his face and he kind of collapses into the wall and he's like, oh, shoot. I'm sorry, Angela. I mean, could it get any worse? He's feeling all of that. He really feels bad. And now he gets Sprinkles's name right the first time. And then he makes a big speech and calls her Prinkles.
所以，你知道。他确实叫了。没错。他说，今天发生了这么多坏事。电脑因为色情内容崩溃，梅雷迪思的事故，现在又是普林克尔斯。我们被诅咒了。这盖棺定论了。对他来说，就是这样。办公室被诅咒了。现在他得想办法打破这个诅咒。是的，但他确实说，我不迷信，但我有点迷信。就像他认为这是两个独立的词。好吧，我们有一个关于那句台词的粉丝问题，来自杰西卡·威利亚德和劳伦·科温。
So, you know. He does. That's right. He says, so many bad things have happened today. The computer crashes from porn, merit of this accident, and now Prinkles. We're cursed. This seals the deal. To him, that's it. The office is cursed. And now he's got to figure out how to break this curse. Yes, but he does say, I'm not superstitious, but I am a little stitious. It's like he thinks they're two separate words. Well, we had a fan question about that line from Jessica, Williard, and Lauren Corwin.
她们说那句台词每次都让我笑，是谁写的这个笑话。我也很好奇。你查到了吗？我查到了。是吉恩·斯图普尼茨基。吉恩？太搞笑了。是的，我问了格雷格，他说，我很确定是吉恩或李。我联系了那些家伙。吉恩说，是的，是我。他记得。
They said that line makes me laugh every time who wrote this joke. I was curious, too. Did you find out? I did. It was Gene Stupnitsky. Gene? Hilarious. Yeah, I asked Greg, and he said, I'm pretty sure it was Gene or Lee. I reached out to those guys. Gene said, yes, it was me. He remembers.
他们在一个小组里，这个独白引出了商业广告。他们需要一个按钮。他们需要在独白结束时有一个小按钮，这样他们就可以进入广告。他说他们只是想出点什么。突然他说他喊道，我有了。这可能很蠢。但这个怎么样？然后他提出了那句台词。
They were in a group and this talking head leads to a commercial break. And they needed a button. They needed a little button at the end of this talking head so that they could go to commercial. And he said they were just trying to come up with something. And all of a sudden he said he shouted out, I've got it. This might be stupid. But how about this? And he pitched that line.
这真是天才。这真是一句好台词。我经常听到那句台词被引用。这是迈克尔·斯科特的经典台词。确实是。没错。好吧，说到经典的迈克尔·斯科特，我们现在要进入迈克尔的会议室会议之一。这是一场史诗般的会议室会议。
And it is so genius. It is such a good line. and I hear that line quoted all the time. It is a Michael Scott classic line. It is. It's true. Well, speaking of classic Michael Scott, we're now going to move into one of Michael's conference room meetings. This is an epic conference room meeting.
我们在那个会议室里待了一整天。我们变得疯疯癫癫的。我们变得很冲动。我要告诉你我们彻底失控的地方。太棒了。是的。我还记得他们非常明确地没有让吉姆和帕姆坐在一起。这是吉姆和帕姆所谓的转移注意力的方式的一部分
We were in this conference room all freaking day. We got loopy. We got punchy. I'm going to tell you where we flat out lost it. It's so good. Yeah. I also remember that they very specifically did not. seat Jim and Pam next to one another. This was part of Jim and Pam's supposed way of deflecting
我们在约会。是的。我记得你必须在这个场景中保持悲伤并哭泣，我不想和你聊太多，因为我知道你必须保持在那个空间里。我确实保持了。我确实保持了。我一直保持悲伤，直到最后史蒂夫让我笑出声来。所以迈克尔在场景中审问他的员工。他觉得一定有人做了什么才导致了这个诅咒，对吧？比如他们是否亵渎了古老的印第安墓地？然后，你知道，他想知道每个人的宗教信仰是什么。托比说，迈克尔，我们不能那样做。
that we're dating. Yeah. And I remember that you have to just be sad and kind of cry through this scene and that I didn't want to chat you up too much because I knew you had to stay in that space. And I did. I did. I really stayed sad until the end when Steve made me break into laughter. So Michael in the scene is questioning his employees. He feels like someone must have done something to get this curse, right? Like have they violated an ancient Indian burial ground? And then, you know, he wants to know what everyone's religious beliefs are. Which Toby says, Michael, we can't do that.
你不能讨论那个。迈克尔在场景中反复称托比为撒旦。第一，因为他赢了一周的免费披萨。所以他说，我不认为有什么诅咒。迈克尔说，好吧，撒旦。所以他绕着房间走。帕姆和达里尔都是长老会教徒。他们击掌。菲利斯有一句很棒的台词，她说，我是路德教徒，鲍勃是唯一神教派，这让生活变得很刺激。嗯哼。
You can't discuss that. Michael calls Toby Satan repeatedly in the scene. One, because he won a week of free pizza. So he's like, I don't think there's a curse. And Michael's like, okay, Satan. So he goes around the room. Pam and Daryl are both Presbyterians. They high five. Phyllis has this great line where she says, I'm a Lutheran and Bob is a Unitarian, keeps things spicy. Mm-hmm.
克里德说他曾经是邪教的追随者，也是邪教的领袖。追随者更有趣，但领袖赚更多的钱。但迈克尔决定他认为也许我们应该进行动物祭祀。是的。那会管用的。也许那会有帮助。是的。嗯哼。然后他开始列举动物，但它们不存在。我把它们写下来了。
Creed said he's been a follower in a cult and a leader in a cult. The followers have more fun, but the leaders make more money. But Michael has decided he thinks maybe we should do an animal sacrifice. Yes. That's going to do it. Maybe that would help. Yeah. Mm-hmm. And then he starts naming animals, but they don't exist. I wrote them down.
他建议我们祭祀一种拥有海象身体和海狮头部的动物，或者拥有白鹭身体和猫鼬头部的动物，或者也许一种拥有猴子头部和猫鼬头部的动物，或者也许一种拥有猴子头部、驯鹿鹿角和豪猪身体的动物。好吧，珍娜，当史蒂夫开始这个梗时，他们只是让他继续。你记得吗？是的。他只是开始即兴发挥不同的动物组合。
He suggests that we sacrifice an animal that has the body of a walrus and the head of a sea lion, or the body of an egret with the head of a mere cat, or maybe one that has the head of a monkey with the head of a mire cat, or maybe one that has the head of a monkey with the antlers of a reindeer and the body of a porcupine. Okay, Jenna, when Steve started this runner, they just let him go. Do you remember this? Yes. He just started improvising different animal combinations.
我们不知道这家伙嘴里会冒出什么。我们都开始像苍蝇一样倒下，笑得前仰后合。另一件事是，他会非常严肃地说出来。这就是喜剧杀手，长长的停顿。他在说“豪猪的身体？”之前停顿了那么久。是的。我们笑得倒在地上。
We didn't know what was going to come out of the guy's mouth. We all started dropping like flies, cracking up. And the other thing is, he would say it with such seriousness. And this was the comedy killer, the long pauses. He takes such a long pause before he says, Body of a Porcupine? Yes. We were on the floor.
我们笑得倒在地上。当他做这些动物组合时，我不在任何背景镜头里，因为我无法控制自己。在18分11秒，你可以看到克雷格·罗宾逊捂着脸。我看到了。我记得那个。我们失控了。太搞笑了。他们让他持续了很长时间。我的意思是，你没有看到全部。他持续了太久。我记得我们笑得前仰后合，我们就像，搞定它。作为一个团队，我们就像，不，振作起来。这些太好了。我们不能毁了它们。好吧，当这一切在办公室发生时，德怀特去探望梅雷迪思了。
We were on the floor. I am not in any background shots while he's doing these animal combinations because I couldn't keep it together. And at 18 minutes, 11 seconds, you can see Craig Robinson covering his face. I saw it. I remember that. We were losing it. It was so funny. And they let him go for a long time. I mean, you are not seeing all of it. He went for so long. And I remember we were cracking up and we were just like, get it. Like as a group, we were like, no, get it together. These are too good. We can't ruin these. Well, while all this is happening at the office, Dwight has gone to visit Meredith.
他有一个独白，他说，当他坐在她旁边时，有时最好的做法是让动物从痛苦中解脱。他是个农民。是的。你可以用梅雷迪思连接的电力给一个小风扇供电两天。我必须说，拜托，如果你回去重看这一集，在德怀特在梅雷迪思床边演讲时，请看看另一边床上的那个女人，好吗，在德怀特的肩膀上方。我只想说这么多，下次你看这个场景时，享受那个表演吧。
and he has this talking head where he's saying, as he's sitting next to her, that sometimes the best thing to do is to put an animal out of its misery. He's a farmer. Yeah. You could power a small fan for two days with the amount of electricity Meredith is hooked up to. I have to say, please, if you go back to rewatch this episode during this speech by Dwight next to Meredith's bedside, please look at the woman in the bed on the other side, okay, over Dwight's shoulder. That's all I'm going to say, just enjoy that performance the next time you watch this scene.
这太美妙了。天哪，珍娜。当我们都挤在凯特的床边时，那个女人就在那里。我发誓，那个女人，就像她是一个真正的病人。她发出某种声音，我以为我们都要吓尿了。她是一个背景演员，但她太真实了。她有一次我们站在那里时，真的发出了，就像，我想他们告诉她也许发出呻吟声。是的。
It's wonderful. Oh, my God, Jenna. When we were all crammed around Kate's bed, that woman was there. I swear, that woman, it was like she was a real patient. She let out some kind of noise, and I thought we were all going to shit our pants. She was a background actor, but she was so real. She literally, while we were standing there one time, went, like, I think they told her to maybe make a moaning sound. Yeah.
而她对那个的诠释，我们都疯了。好吧，在场景的背景中看着她，因为她太出色了。现在医生进来了，德怀特对他有一些问题。你和我都知道这是我们的编剧，贾斯汀·斯皮策。是的，你最喜欢的一些德怀特主义的创造者，贾斯汀·斯皮策。也是《超级商店》的创作者。好吧，我联系了贾斯汀，他告诉我他在剧本朗读会上读了这个角色后得到了这个角色。他让格雷格笑了。
And her interpretation of that, we went loopy. Well, watch her in the background of the scene because she's excellent. So now the doctor comes in and Dwight has some questions for him. And you and I both know that this is our writer, Justin Spitzer. Yes, creator of some of your favorite Dwightisms, Justin Spitzer. And the creator of the show, Superstore. Well, I reached out to Justin and he told me that he got this role after reading the part in the table read. That he made Greg laugh.
保罗·利伯斯坦分享过这种情况会发生。他们不会把一些角色定下来，他们会让编剧读。如果编剧读了一个角色，准备好。因为格雷格，格雷格很有可能把你放进剧里。好吧，他还告诉我，他给镜头的那个眼神实际上是他误解了格雷格的一条指示。格雷格并不打算让他像个小笑话一样对着镜头表演那句台词。就像，哦，原来是这样。
Which Paul Lieberstein has shared that this would happen. They wouldn't have some of the roles cast and they would have riot. Writers read them. And if a writer read apart, get ready. Because Greg, there was a good chance Greg was going to put you in the show. Well, he also told me that the look he gives to camera was actually him misunderstanding a piece of direction from Greg. That Greg did not intend him to, like, perform that line to the camera as like a little joke. Like, oh, so that's where it went.
他在谈论梅雷迪思的子宫。是的。但格雷格把它留下了。我喜欢它。我也喜欢，但他说那不是本意。那是个错误。好吧，我们在这一幕中了解到梅雷迪思被蝙蝠咬了，我们知道这一点，但不仅是被蝙蝠咬了，最近还被浣熊和老鼠咬了。梅雷迪思，搞什么鬼？她在做什么？老实说，其中一些动物可能就住在她的货车里。
He's talking about Meredith's uterus. Yeah. But Greg left it in. I liked it. I liked it too, but he said that was not the intention. That was a mistake. Well, we learn in this scene that Meredith has been bitten by a bat, which we knew, but not only by a bat, but recently by a raccoon and a rat. What the hell, Meredith? What is she doing? Honestly, a few of those animals could just live in her van.
梅雷迪思的货车。好吧，当德怀特从医院回来时，他向迈克尔汇报了这一切，他说，你知道，事实证明梅雷迪思接触过狂犬病。迈克尔就像，叮，叮，叮，叮。去医院可能救了她的命，因为她打了狂犬病疫苗。这就是迈克尔需要听到的全部。他开车撞了她，救了她的命。是的。现在，他在这一幕中也说，德怀特说，治疗狂犬病的唯一方法是，
Meredith's van. Well, when Dwight comes back from the hospital, he fills Michael in on all of this, he says, you know, it turns out Meredith had been exposed to rabies. Michael's like, ding, ding, ding, ding. And that going to the hospital might have saved her life because she got a rabies vaccine. That is all Michael needed to hear. He hit her with a car and saved her life. Yes. Now, he also says in this scene, Dwight says, the only way to treat rabies is,
是在症状开始前开始治疗。好吧，我查了一下。这是真的。你知道吗，安吉拉，几乎100%出现症状的人都会死于狂犬病？死。一旦你得了它，就无法治愈。我不知道这一点。是的，这就是为什么你必须立即寻求治疗
is to start treatment before the symptoms start. Well, I looked it up. This is true. Did you know, Angela, that nearly 100% of people who develop symptoms die from rabies? Die. It cannot be cured once you get it. I did not know that. Yes, so this is why you have to seek treatment immediately
如果你被动物咬了。很多动物都能携带狂犬病，但既然我查过了，我会让你知道在美国，传播狂犬病最可能的方式是通过蝙蝠、土狼、狐狸、浣熊和臭鼬。在非洲和东南亚，是流浪狗。我的意思是，猴子呢？像印度尼西亚的部分地区，比如，如果你去乌布，到处都是猴子。任何动物咬伤。如果你被任何动物咬了，就去。
if you are ever bitten by an animal. And a lot of animals can carry rabies, But since I looked it up, I'll let you know that in the United States, the most likely way to transmit rabies is through bats, coyotes, foxes, raccoons, and skunks. In Africa and Southeast Asia, it is stray dogs. I mean, what about monkeys? There's parts of, like, Indonesia, like, if you go up to Ubud, like, there's monkeys, like all over the place. Any animal bite. If you get bitten by any animal, just go.
去打狂犬病疫苗。它还说。松鼠呢？是的，任何动物。如果任何动物咬你，我只是告诉你这些地方最可能携带狂犬病的动物，但任何动物都能传染给你。猫鼬在名单上吗？猫鼬是任何动物吗？我只是在开玩笑，但这真的很有趣。好吧，听着，这是我发现最有趣的事情。这是来自梅奥诊所网站。
Go get a rabies vaccine. It also said. What about squirrels? Yes, any animal. If any animal bites you, I'm just telling you the animals that are most likely to carry rabies in these locations, but any animal can give it to you. Is a mongoose on the list? Is a mongoose any animal? I'm just messing with you, but it's been really fun. Well, listen, here is the thing that I found most interesting. This is from the Mayo Clinic website.
这是它说的。好吧。如果你早上醒来。好吧。你的房间里有一只蝙蝠。好吧。你应该假设你被咬了。因为蝙蝠可以在不吵醒你的情况下咬你。
Here's what it says. Okay. If you wake up in the morning. Okay. And there's a bat in your room. Okay. You should assume you've been bitten. Because a bat can bite you without waking you up.
它还说如果你发现一个无法告诉你是否被咬的人身边有一只蝙蝠，比如孩子或受损的成年人，假设他们也被咬了，去打狂犬病疫苗。因为一旦你表现出症状，就没有治愈方法。好吧，我正在看一集《我们的星球》，他们谈论这些小海豹，有吸血蝙蝠去试图吸它们的血，它们会跳。它们跳来跳去。海豹是蝙蝠。蝙蝠！
It also said if you find a bat by a person who can't tell you that they've been bitten like a child or an impaired adult, assume they have also been bitten and go get a rabies vaccine. Because once you show you. symptoms, there is no cure. Well, I was watching an episode of Our Planet, and they were talking about these baby seals, and there are vampire bats that go and try to just suck their blood, and they can hop. They hop around. The seals are the bats. The bats!
它们跳。我会给你发个视频。它们跳，它们是吸血鬼。它们跳然后咬。它们跳然后咬。是的。好吧，伙计们，就是这样。就是这样。这是你的狂犬病小抄。这就是你想知道的关于狂犬病的一切。基本上，如果你被动物咬了，这就是我学到的。去打那个狂犬病疫苗。好。哦，是的。这就是我希望得到的收获。好吧，就是这样。迈克尔很高兴发现他救了梅雷迪思的命。哦，是的。他走进办公室。他宣布诅咒已经被打破了。事实证明有上帝。一切都很棒。但耶稣的爸爸是谁？是的，我想他不确定。与此同时，凯文，你知道，一直在调查，这一整集都在试图
They jump. I'm going to send you a video. They hop, and they are bloodsuckers. They hop and bite. They hop and bite. Yeah. Well, there you go, guys. There you go. That's your rabies cheat sheet. That's everything you ever wanted to know about rabies. Basically, if you get bit by an animal, that's what I learned. Get that rabies shot. Good. Oh, yes. That was the takeaway I was hoping for. Well, there you go. Well, Michael is thrilled to find out that he has saved Meredith's life. Oh, yeah. He walks into the bullpen. He declares that the curse has. has been broken. Turns out there is a God. Everything is great. But who is Jesus's dad? Yeah, he's not sure, I guess. And meanwhile, Kevin, you know, has been on the case, this whole episode trying to
弄清楚吉姆和帕姆是否在约会，他确信他们是。但已经是这一天的结束了。他说，你知道吗？我想他们没在一起。现在他们可能永远不会在一起了。这太糟糕了，因为他们就像PB&J。帕姆·比斯利和吉姆。是的，那是一个内部笑话，因为在这一点上，剧集的粉丝开始叫吉姆和帕姆“果酱”。是的。他们把我们的名字合并成了果酱。所以凯文叫我们PB&J而不是果酱是一件很有趣的事情。
figure out if Jim and Pam are dating, he's positive that they are. But it's the end of the day. And he's like, you know what? I guess they're not together. And now they probably never will be. And it's too bad because they're like P.B and J. Pam Beasley and Jim. Yeah. And that was an inside joke because at this point, fans of the show had started calling Jim and Pam jam. Yes. They had mashed our names as jam. And so it was this funny thing that Kevin would call us PB&J and not jam.
对粉丝的一点致意。一点致意。好吧，你知道吗？我们看到帕姆下班离开了。她上了车。她开车走了。她一个人。显然，纪录片摄制组和凯文一样怀疑，因为他们跟着她开车离开。
A little nod to the fans. A little nod. Well, you know what? We see Pam leave for the day. She gets in her car. She drives away. She's by herself. Clearly, the documentary crew is as suspicious as Kevin because they follow her as she drives off.
这让我怀疑，天哪，我们下班后他们跟着我们多久？好吧，我觉得你不应该那么担心，因为帕姆开车没走多远。我当时想，帕姆，做得更好点。你开了大约四个车位然后就靠边停车了。然后呢？你打算就把你的车留在那里吗？你的车离工作地点不远，你打算就把它留在那里？不，我不会把它留在那里。
It made me wonder, my gosh, how long do they follow us after we leave work? Well, I don't think you should be that worried because Pam doesn't drive very far. I was like, Pam, do better. You drove like four car lengths and then you pulled over. And then what? Are you going to just leave your car there? Your car is not that far from work and you're just going to leave it? No, I'm not going to leave it.
我要去接吉姆。我觉得他们本可以做得更好。好吧，你知道吗？这是我们可以获得许可的街道，我们不能封锁整条街道。这就是我被允许开的最远距离。但这是真的。我靠边停车。然后格雷格想进一步推进误导。
I'm going to pick up gym. I think they could have done better. Well, you know what? This is the street we could get a permit for, and we couldn't block off the whole street. This is as far as I was allowed to drive. But it's true. I pull over. And then Greg wanted to kind of further the misdirect.
所以他指导我把头放在方向盘上。就像也许帕姆把车停在路边是因为她只是有一种情绪化的时刻。也许你会发现那是什么，或者为什么她很伤心之类的。但当然发生的事情是吉姆过来了。他上了车。他们分享了一个吻，然后开车走了。好吧，我喜欢我们看到的这个小时刻。我会说这个。
So he directed me to put my head down on the steering wheel. Like maybe Pam pulled off the side of the road because she was just having kind of an emotional moment. And maybe you'd find out what that was or why that was that she was sad or something like that. But of course what happens is Jim comes over. He gets in the car. They share a kiss and then they drive away. Well, I loved this little moment that we got to see. I will say this.
你趴在方向盘上的方式，我不认为你被情绪淹没了。我以为你在尴尬地试图躲藏。我要说当我回看那个镜头时，这是我在剧中最糟糕的表演时刻之一。我以为你在试图躲藏。想法是我有点像，哦，多么糟糕的一天。我需要靠边停车，因为，哦，这是多么糟糕的一天。我需要一点时间来整理自己。我的意思是，它没起作用。
The way you slumped on the steering wheel, I did not think you were overcome with the motion. I thought you were awkwardly trying to hide. I'm going to say when I watched that back, it's one of my worst acting moments on the show. I thought you were trying to hide. The idea was that I was sort of like, oh, what a day. I needed to pull over because, oh, what a day this has been. I need a moment to collect myself. I mean, it didn't work.
我不认为它起作用了。你以为我在试图躲在方向盘里。我以为它起作用了，因为我以为帕姆可能试图遮住她的脸，不让任何可能离开的同事看到，因为她离大楼没开多远。好吧，我就是这么想的。这很奇怪。这很奇怪。但就是这样。在DVD上，伙计们，有一个非常有趣的额外功能。
I don't think it worked. You thought I was trying to hide in my steering wheel. I thought it worked because I thought Pam was trying to possibly cover her face from anyone of her coworkers who might be leaving since she didn't pull very far away from the building. Well, that's what I thought. It was strange. It was strange. But there you go. And on the DVDs, guys, there is a very interesting extra feature.
有一个狂犬病公益广告。史蒂夫看起来像史蒂夫，可爱的牛仔裤，扣子衬衫。他有正常的史蒂夫发型。但他表现得更像迈克尔，但他还是史蒂夫。我不知道。就像它是为迈克尔写的，但由史蒂夫表演。这是一个狂犬病公益广告。还记得NBC上的那些东西吗？
There is a rabies PSA. It is Steve looking like Steve, cute jeans, button down. He has normal Steve hair. But he's sort of delivering it more like Michael, but he's Steve. I don't know. It's like it was written for Michael, but it's delivered by Steve. It's a rabies PSA. Remember those things on NBC?
是的。比如“你知道的越多”，叮，叮，叮，之类的。是的。他给了一些关于狂犬病的建议。然后他说，狂犬病每1000年杀死近4000名美国人。好吧，这是我发现的一个有趣的事实，安吉拉。什么？哪一个？那就是。这一集播出后的第二天，这一集在2007年9月27日播出，第二天是第一个年度世界狂犬病日。这是一个提高狂犬病意识的全球健康日。所以你认为NBC让史蒂夫拍了一个公益广告吗？
Yes. Like the more, you know, Bing, Bing, Bing, or whatever. Yes. And he's giving a few, like, tips about rabies. And then he says, rabies kills nearly 4,000 Americans every 1,000 years. Well, here's an interesting fact that I found, Angela. What? Which is that? The day after this episode aired, this episode aired on September 27, 2007, The next day was the first annual World Rabies Day. It was a global health day to raise awareness of rabies. So do you think NBC had Steve do a PSA?
我不知道。我不知道。但这真是一件奇怪、疯狂的事情。是的，伙计们，如果你被咬了，去打那个狂犬病疫苗。我希望我在今天的剧集中说清楚了。我明白了。我希望你也学到了也许不要在有很早的通告时间之前喝三杯玛格丽特。
I don't know. I don't know. But what a weird, crazy thing. Yes. And guys, if you get bit, get that rabies shot. I hope I made that clear in today's episode. I got it. I hope you also learned maybe don't drink three margaritas before you have a real early call time.
有抱负的演员们，也许你们今天也可以从我这里学到这一点。珍娜，你今天给了各种各样的宝石。太多的宝石了。好吧，谢谢。不客气。这是我今天从中学到的。保存无聊的电子邮件，然后没人会黑你。没错。哦，就是这样。伙计们，那是《趣味跑》，第一部分。我们下周会带着《趣味跑》第二部分回来，
Aspiring actors, maybe you can learn that from me today as well. Jenna, you're giving all kinds of gems today. So many gems. Well, thank you. You're welcome. Here's the takeaway from me today. Save the boring emails and then no one will hack you. That's right. Oh, there we go. Guys, that was Fun Run, Part 1. We'll be back next week with Fun Run Part 2,
我们真的在跑。哦，天哪，我们跑了吗？好吧，伙计们，祝你们有愉快的一周。再见。嗨。你还在吗？再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·吉尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
where we actually run. Oh, man, do we? All right, guys, have a great week. Bye. Hi. Are you still here? Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们实际上是在哪里跑步。天哪，我们是吗？好了，伙计们，祝你们度过愉快的一周。再见。嗨。你还在吗？再见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·吉尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。